and it is the end it all comes down to
this in chess.com puzzle week
it's the puzzle battle world chess
championship and alongside me
a guy that i i want to start calling mr
puzzles on chest i don't know why
because i know how much you love puzzles
maurice but i'm i'll just go with
grandmaster maurice ashley for now
that'll work makes sense we are we are
here to see some of the best in the
world maurice and i know
i don't know how many people know this
about you but you're you're not only a
puzzle aficionado
and lover of it but you make your own
puzzles so how excited are you to see
guys like ray robson guys like the the
guy that came out of nowhere from greece
demetrius this guy who has been a
roughly 2300 player but maybe maybe one
of the best puzzle solvers on the planet
how excited are you today to see what
these specialists can do well you know
back in the day
the king was john none part excellence i
mean it's like
that guy could look at any puzzle and
solve it i don't care how abstract
how obscure how incredibly esoteric
looking it's like the guy would just be
like
boo and just get it now to see these
young guns come up
and see tactics just like that or see
unusual themes that
you just don't see every day and
suddenly they're able to spot them
in seconds it's actually kind of
depressing on one end because you spend
a lot of time
creating a puzzle and these guys are
solving it like no problem this is easy
it's extraordinary to see their
abilities it takes pattern recognition
to a whole
mind-blowing level and one that i'm i'm
always in awe of because i can't put up
scores no matter how hard i try to
compete with these guys but
all right let's run through the details
of what is coming up today we got things
to remind the fans of the format the
prizes let's jump in right now so
remember first and foremost we have free
puzzles
all day long here on january 8th so if
you haven't been paying close attention
to chess.com's puzzle week it's okay
even if you're not a premium member
today's your day to dive in
play puzzle battle all day no
limitations and have a blast with it
the format of day five is exactly what
we're about to get into it's the puzzle
battle championship like we said not
only free puzzles for all users but we
have an eight player
single elimination bracket these are
really the best of the best right we've
got guys like hicaro and nbl who are
those household
super grand master names but then we
we've got ray robson
we've got uh demetrius lot of houlos
we've got all these guys lined up
and remember one of the fun things about
today maurice is it's winner
take all as we bring up the prizes here
eight thousand dollars for first place
everybody else is going home with
nothing you like that i know you like
that
it's brutal look they've already won
money to get here yes
so this is the championship of
championships this puts
the nerves on the line i mean you know
it's winner go home this really is like
the final four you know the sweet 16 all
the the great battles that we love to
see
it's make it or break it so this is
what's up i love this
yep um the uh the bracket as you said
um is uh is the best players they've
already they've gotten a little bit of
something to get here many of these guys
have been playing throughout puzzle week
but
but these are the guys that got the
direct invitations to play in
the puzzle battle championship um well
we go down the list right it's it's an
interesting
an interesting balance of star names
guys like ikaru and maxine bashed the
grav who are faced off in the first
round
but you've also got ray robson versus
eric hanson there the one eight seed
matchup right you've got
jeffrey zhang versus dania naradiski
which is going to be awesome and then
you've got
christopher you this this young
incredible talent maybe a future us
champion
on the rise right against the the guy
that no one really wants to lose to and
i say that kind of jokingly because he's
not a title player and we know that we
you know professionals work super hard
they've got egos right no one wants to
lose to a guy that's not a professional
player but he sent
he sent international after grand master
home last year
well look but the reality is that this
is a special
skill set when you're a title player
you've got the whole package you've got
the open
you've got the end game technique right
you know about
game management that's a whole different
thing
than solving puzzles you can be a puzzle
specialist that's one of the great
things about chess
you can be a specialist in an activity
so i don't think people are gonna feel
too much embarrassment losing to a
non-title player
because they know if they have to play
this guy in a regular chess game it'll
be spanx city
but puzzles this is clearly what he's
interested in
and hey we you got to take him down in
this specialty
yep and i i got to be honest i think if
one one sort of surprised
kid young young player who could do it
it might be christopher you this guy has
been
just an absolute monster not just in
puzzles but over the board recently we
see
we've seen him make huge strides this
year in 2020 as a chess player
and uh and he was a guy i think if i'm
remembering last year correctly that
made it to the semi-finals um so uh
we'll see how that shakes out
but okay the big big matchup the one of
the two big names we got to talk about
right
hikaru nakamura versus mvl they they
start out
by rating in the first round right so
that wasn't engineered by us we love it
when we get marquee match-ups we're not
going to lie here as chess commentators
and entertainers
uh but uh but we got lucky with this one
because in the first round
we've got star power and only one of
these guys will be moving on to the
semis
i have a hard time picking this one we
know hikaru is going to be streaming we
see what he's capable of we've seen it
all
chess.com puzzle week but nbl's getting
ready for uh todd of steel there in
viking z we know he arrived
if you follow him on social media this
is a literal coin flip to me maurice
you know i i'm sorry naca
is always going to be the favorite in my
book in almost any activity he does
and magnus carlsen is not in it okay if
it's classical chess he hasn't been
really
focused on that as much and so his level
has somewhat dropped off
but if it's about speed and it's online
i don't care who you've got if you take
magnus out of it
naca is my guy so you say coin flip
uh i say knock a flip okay well let's
see what these guys have done
historically right we know they're all
super good but amazing when we talk
about uh hikaru and
and maxine we see them very very close
within one in terms of their all-time
best and three minute puzzle rush now
remember
why are we why are we choosing three
minutes to show here fans because puzzle
battles the only time control we have
currently is three-minute chess
that feels like the best way to get
everybody an opportunity to get a quick
puzzle battle versus someone and as as
the popularity of puzzle battles has
continued to grow
we are working on more time controls
five minutes in other formats but right
now
three minute puzzle rush is the most
direct comparison to a puzzle battle
match up
as far as what numbers these guys are
capable of putting up and there you have
it in front of you right ray robson
and demetrius they're in the high 60s
which is just like
mind-blowing right um but uh anyway and
then we've got everyone else there
kind of kind of a big drop but but still
very very close and uh
and yeah so all right well i think i
think we're getting set here to start um
if the
if i'm if i'm following our run of show
correctly welcome everybody again if
you're just tuning in we've already got
more than 500
of you on youtube what's going on over
here on twitch we got a few thousand
almost four thousand
it's gonna be quite the day today so
don't go anywhere and uh i think the
matchups are are getting set to begin
soon maurice now danny i gotta tell you
i i did this commentary earlier in the
week i was watching you
and amman do your thing together
struggle through those puzzles
yeah i know i know but let me let me say
doing commentary on puzzles is the
hardest commentary
for them like it and doing and that was
survival mode it wasn't even super fast
trying to to do this to me it's like i'm
in virgin territory i'm coming in and
saying
i'm gonna do three minute puzzles like
they're gonna be going by like that like
so
super duper quick and that's what we're
here for is to see the speed
but it's going to be hard to actually
comment on a puzzle because
the plus is going to come up you're
going to say i think it's bit and then
they're going to have solved it and
they're gone so it's gonna be intriguing
to really try to figure this out how to
actually
do good commentary when things are going
this lightning fast be a blur
in front of us agreed totally and i can
already tell you that last year
um i think i had the call of the final
with with robert if i remember correctly
and it was
it was exactly as you described in fact
most of our uh
edutainment for the fans really came
after the puzzle battle run was over we
could say hey let's go back to that one
critical puzzle
you know that that either won it or or
blew it for the guy right because
um right now i can already see that uh
and we're gonna pull it up here for
everyone in just a second but
the puzzles are already rolling and um
these guys are solving a mile a minute
and here we go
as you can see we've got ray robson
versus eric hanson
and unfortunately for the canadian he's
already dropped a red x right in front
of us
never good and so far behind as well i
mean this
yeah 26-18 that's that's
a big lead and ray is known to run up
the score badly i mean you saw his
number
as a big record how can you just you
just glance at the chess board
and see what to do instantly and these
these puzzles are the exact same puzzles
they're seeing right because it's
well and some they've seen before and it
sounds crazy because we have more than
75 000 puzzles just above the 2900 level
let alone i mean there are so many
puzzles in the database but
but these guys um a funny story maurice
i'll share because
you probably weren't following this
closely in in 2018 and 2019 when we
first launched puzzle rush
it was so popular that guys like ray
robson and demetrius
basically forced us to to redo our
algorithm that found
high level we'll call it the 2800 plus
puzzles because there were about 10 000
at the time and they memorized them
and and so they basically broke they
broke the puzzle rush by
by memorizing the puzzles and at the
time spicy caterpillar was actually an
anonymous
user no one knew that rey was spicy
caterpillar and i made him
i made him go unanimous because i said
hey man you got to take the heat off me
like people have no idea who you are
are you cheating what's going on so we
made his ray robson account
basically retired and made this his
public account because he was just
he had blown everybody's minds with the
scores he was putting up cleanly
but through memorization it was nuts
yeah
even that's extraordinary when you think
about it right 10 000 puzzles to have
that down
on top i mean the fact that he's a 2600
grandmaster
does help because he can
you can memorize and see great moves at
the same time as well
but there is definitely an art to
solving these puzzles
quickly if you've never seen them before
and i mean
just to just see them instantly have the
reflex action
to see exactly what to do it's it's
incredible
it's just incredible you see there that
already eric is
done you see three three strikes ray's
just
crazy i mean a train let's let's jump
over to another one i i pulled up i
think we've got um okay we got oh wow
look at this we got zhong and neroditsky
with four this is coming down to the
wire oh nerdisky just misses third never
mind jung won i'm sorry
wow brutal brutally are any of them
still going i'm gonna check the other
tabs looks like
demetrius did take care of christopher
you with a 54-43 score
our our nakamura mvl one didn't quite
load we'll get on that but
you see ray putting up a 57 not his
all-time 69 but
as you and i were describing maurice i
mean we can go back what was the one
that really had me just
blown away i'm gonna try to find it real
quick here we had this uh
one of these where he just he just
absolutely just crushed it without even
being able to
rook a2 one of the ones he solved i i
never i can't even find it
i guess we if we wanted to we could go
back to uh mr mr um hansen
and see where he got a few wrong but
okay before we do
let's just bring up a recap of what the
scores were in round one
um this is where we stand any surprises
to you
other than the fact that apparently
hikaru and nbl didn't manage to get
their match off the ground
i got a phone ringing in the background
to deal with one second but
um this there are running right now
maurice so let's just tune into that
because this is whoa
hicaro misses his first puzzle and we
have a super tight race at 36 a piece
okay wow i hey one of the things about
this
everyone is that even though hicaro has
missed one it kind of doesn't matter as
oh
now maybe it does because now you got to
slow down you've
you've made that second strike right but
in this particular situation
the high score is all that matters
remember that so even if you missed two
along the way but we see hikaru
ikaro misses third so not his best start
here
mbl actually already has this one
wrapped up at 41
and uh and we've still got a minute to
go but he should try to go remember the
the scores matter as far as what you're
able to put up and so nbl should not
just give up here even though he's
already got this first round in the bag
yeah just just extraordinary to see
you know the thing about this is when
you are doing these puzzles
what when you mess up there's something
in your brain
that just just kicks you for a second
that you feel terrible
even if it's just one even if it's just
right you're just like
damn i didn't want to mess up that one
and then when you mess up a second time
then you feel all the pressure because
you know the third mess up and you're
done
so that's really what this is about you
got to get into flow
and as your flow is just going you you
you don't care if you mess one up
because you're like no problem i got the
confidence
that i'm not going to mess up again
that's the top top level guys
to be able to pull that off but
psychologically it's brutal when you're
trying to solve these things
at that rapid pace no you and you make a
great point about that second strike is
really where
you know you start to see the you know
the momentum shift because with one
strike you don't slow down an inch but a
second strike and that's really exactly
what happened to acaro as we saw kind of
his
his run there and when he got when he
messed up on 38 he messed up right away
on 39 so
all right so now we're going to bring up
the scores again the first round is
completely in the books
uh the technical difficulty there slowed
down recaro and mbl but it's actually
maybe not a bad thing it allows us to
focus on that marquee match up so
no surprises um necessarily maurice
other than
i guess uh mbl right the one that we
said was a coin flip
putting the pressure on naka to start
things off absolutely
absolutely that's a big deal but you
know what we've seen naka before let's
be real
naka is the kind of guy who when his
head
is literally in the lion's mouth that's
when he says
okay things have gotten interesting now
now it's fun
now it's fine naco just seems
i call him hydra you cut off one head
two more grow it's just the way he is so
i'm not worried about him
he's the one guy you know if you're if
you're down
call him over because he'll say look
we're gonna make this come back
and he means that he's got ice water in
his veins
absolutely and and he i don't expect him
to go away after the uh the the first
start and
and i actually think that the score that
mdl put up 40
47 is probably what we're going to see
all day between these guys is a score in
the mid 40s
um that uh and you know who gets the
better of it obviously will depend but
all right here we go we've got our next
round
underway between mvl and hikaru and i
think we'll keep it right here given
that we
we didn't give them the attention they
needed at the start but okay we've got
both sides solving away hikaru about a
puzzle
maybe a puzzle and a half behind mvl
maybe not he's caught up
all right we see them just these are the
easy ones we're just winning pieces
uh pretty readily checkmates
directly as well uh there you see a nice
little
checkmate going on just a little bit
behind
it looks like is mvl at the moment a
16-15 score
as they're just rocking these puzzles
one of the problems with the with the
puzzle
the easy ones no problem but what
sometimes you think it's easy and it
turns out that
there was a small wrinkle and those are
the worst ones by the way
i hate when that happens in puzzle rush
you're doing a puzzle
your solution is good but it wasn't
exactly the perfect solution
and you you get angry at the
the game for throwing you a puzzle that
had a couple of good solutions but
one was just better than the other yep
i i i think that that's one of the ones
that that really leaves a mark when you
feel frustrated that you feel like you
found a winning idea but like you said
it um it's not good enough not good
enough right
um look at this naka showing numbers now
two up will he keep the two-point lead
as he's just whipping out
these solutions uh he's streaming yes
but he's not talking yes
yeah he knows he's up against it
usually naka is running his mouth uh
saying some stuff
chilling bobbing his head there is no
head bopping
and no talking right now well let's
let's take a listen in on hikaru because
of what you're saying this is not the
normal stream de caro you're right he is
zoned in
wow that was a tough find he's not even
talking
no he's not talking he's not doing
this he knows who he's up against
wow and he hasn't missed yet still on a
44 score
wow i just okay i'm gonna try to say i
would have found that
like this is a tough one and he knows it
okay
oh my gosh this is tough
check wow that's nice he almost messed
it up but he found the skewer at the end
um
look at that we missed that didn't he
notice the message being sent maurice
a 48 score higher than what nbl got in
the first round
he's back i told you
okay this one oh ah i want to get
ah not good whatever whatever it's still
good it's still good it's still good
whatever still good i wanted to get
all right we'll come back that was funny
you see the frustration of him not
getting 50 which is his all-time best in
three-minute
um let's see what happened in the other
matchups looks like
uh ray took down eric hanson again
with a 56-40 score not his 57 maurice
but a 56 pretty good
we see that uh jeffrey young took down
oh wow we
i think next round we've got to give
some focus here i also know donna is
streaming but
if i'm not mistaken that's two rounds
that have been super close between these
two guys
um oh wait maybe it didn't refresh maybe
it's possible that this is actually the
score
from the previous round i think that's
actually more likely um
because uh as we as we go back to the
observing
the observing tab i think i think up
nope we lost it my bad on that
we've uh we will we'll try to make sure
that these uh
these are being refreshed properly but
this was the score from the first round
and if we bring up those scores from the
second round here
they actually tied look at that 43 a
piece
that makes sense sooner or later people
are going to tie in these
they're going so quickly and there's a
number of opportunities
but we see we do see one
dominant match and that's ray just
racking up numbers against eric
this this will this is not he's not
going to catch him i mean
this is just not going to happen yeah i
mean eric eric
is um obviously a super strong
grandmaster
right um and uh you know
i think i think otb chess level maurice
these two guys would be very close i
think hanson maybe maybe ray has uh
a bit of an edge on on on eric these
days but when it comes to puzzles
ray is the reigning puzzle battle world
champion for a reason right
and uh eric is a bit of a bit of a
streamer kind of wild card right we know
he's super capable but
he already knew taking the 8th seed that
he was going to have an uphill battle
against the beast
the beast known as spicy caterpillar
look
let's be real and later on my show my
twitch stream i'm going to talk about
this
the reality is puzzle solving as we said
is puzzle solving that's that's a skill
set
it's only one aspect of chess and you
can see players
you could magnus could go against the
best puzzle solvers in the world and
lose
and you'll say wait but he's magnus
carlson he should be able to dominate at
everything
no that's not how it works it doesn't
work like that in sports
it doesn't work like that in chess there
are specific things that you can do well
and magnus doesn't need to speed solve
puzzles
when he is whooping on you in a chess
game he doesn't need to do that
he just needs to see the move when he's
playing and go i see the move i just may
not be able to do the mouse thing
in half a second so that's the reality
of it so we let's not compare chess
ability chess abilities and and think
that somehow
this is reflecting that because they're
able to do the solving of the puzzles
faster
where do you think i mean that said
obviously you love puzzles we know that
puzzles can be very beneficial for
someone's chest so where would you feel
that line crosses like
people should spend time solving puzzles
because it develops pattern recognition
and these tactical patterns occur in
their games
so that you get the dub right but but
then there's like the line of
now you're solving like compositions and
things like that like where would you
feel most people need to get as far as
their puzzle rating
or puzzle understanding not not to
become a specialist but to you know
maybe reach like the master level in
chess
look this is a very different thing when
you're talking about
numbers uh in in puzzle rush
it's it's the quality of the patterns of
that you're solving not this necessarily
the speed at which you're solving it
puzzle rush is a lot of fun you're
instinctive you can see these ideas very
quickly
but the the greatness of puzzle rush to
me
is the variety of puzzles you're seeing
right between
great numbers different types of
tactical situations
you're not you don't know you're looking
for a queen sack right now
this is about pins right this this is
all interference tactics
puzzler says we're going to give you us
an extreme variety of different puzzles
and if you've mastered all these ideas
then when you come to do puzzle rush
you'll do really well
especially if you practice so you can go
faster so to me that's really the
greatness of puzzle rush
the more you can solve it's an indicator
of the work you've put in away from
puzzle rush
right and that it's the great test it's
the great test for you
to see if you can see the tactics you're
supposed to know
that's it that's a great way to put it i
think the uh
okay well before i we could talk chess
and puzzle philosophy all day but these
two guys are probably our closest first
round match up everyone if you're tuning
in look at that scoreboard we saw
jeffrey jean got the better
by only two in the first round at 45
then they tied
but now donya is up by three with only
30 seconds left so this is the
both players with two strikes here
maurice a lot of nerves on the line here
absolutely a single blunder could cost
and right now we see he has slowed down
has done he doesn't see the next move
yeah i i don't see him making another
move as jeffrey has just caught up to
him
the same puzzle same puzzle and jeffrey
knows it he's solving it
blown by him is he's
he's just he's just not moving what's
going on he won
he's won donya couldn't make another
move what a comeback
that was extraordinary he did he could
not find
another move but does that make any
sense
it doesn't make any sense it almost
seems like it was white to move and i
wonder if uh
i'll do the thing where we give a hard
refresh i want to make sure before we
give any opinion that that's indeed what
happened yeah
somehow donya oh danya missed this
tactic and we just hadn't seen the third
x that was why donya played bishop b2
maurice
instead of bishop g1 and rook h6 which
was the answer
that jeffrey found if we go back to this
puzzle here everyone look
don you played bishop b2 over there on
the right but the move was actually
bishop g1 king h3 rook h6 check and then
rook takes h2 with a skewer so
we were we just weren't seeing the third
x but actually
and that cost him what a comeback as
jeffrey came
from behind to find the key move in that
puzzle and that's such a good point
he won he played bishop to be too
thinking
i mean he's a great player but he
thought this is going to work because
the rook is cut off
right positional idea a great positional
idea the king has to move over
to h to the h file the rook goes over to
the h bar and the other rook drops into
c2
that's what he thought was was needed
but
jeffrey instantly realized i get a
skewer with the beautiful
bishop to g1 that that was boss
and that is what won him this round
pretty cool pretty cool great crazy
stuff and uh
and yeah we see that it means jeffrey
jung leads their overall battle if we
bring up the scores by a total of three
puzzles
he won by two in the first round and
then by one there
and the way the scoring system works if
we
have the ability to bring up a format
card for that we'll we'll work on that
but the scoring system is each round is
worth a certain amount of points
um and uh but you also keep track of the
total amount
of puzzles solved in case we come down
to a tiebreaker
uh meaning the rounds are split so um
well
one when we did miss maurice is clearly
hikaru
tsm hikaru as he's known has has made
his comeback proving your prediction
correct
he's now up two rounds to one or if you
just look at the total amount of puzzles
he's actually up significantly he won by
14 in round two and then he just won by
six
in the third round right there did i say
hydra
what did i say you cut off one head two
more show what's it what are we going to
score now
first round the head was cut off what
happened two more group
the guy is just a beast he is never
losing confidence in any situation it
doesn't matter what
and yeah he's showing his stuff right
now well it's why the fans love him we
see he's uh he's streaming right now to
about 22
000 of you over on twitch.tv slash gm
hikaru so uh
and he's head-bopping from what i can
tell he's head-bopping he's eating
actually the snack
i mean i mean this guy's looking this is
the hikaru we're used to
he's probably going to start talking in
a moment as well
because he's just he's just such a
confident
baller when it comes to chess and the
moves look at this
like blur finding tactical ideas
i mean just incredible in his mouth
skill
danny i think i would get a hand cramp
if i try to move this fast
i mean literally i might have to get a
massage i call in
call in the physical therapist please as
i try to move this fast
because this is ridiculous how he just
blitzes through moves
brain to hand to screen just incredible
it'll throw your back out to move that
fast as they say right i mean i'm too
old for that an old an old chess injury
coming back to bite me
uh if i move that fast so i agreed with
you and let's listen in to hikaru
and see what he's talking about
he does have one strike against him
though so he's
that's kind of annoying because he don't
want to get that second strike
and they're just picking off pieces here
the queen in trouble going
there he has to be mindful so he can win
the rook because one chance of winning
the rook on the other side this looks
like a mating attack against the queen
there
great and now he should win the queen in
this position there you go
and now just realizing the check will
just pick basic tactics is 101
as he's real any alignment that will
just lead to
to winning pieces as pieces drop off
simply incredible now he's got to find
the right place
so that that one was annoying that was
annoying
to find the right spot for your king
that is not a typical pattern
and and that's what puzzle rush will do
to you to hurt you because you got to
find the exact spot for your
king what what's the deal i'm trying to
win and you're telling me i got to
defend properly
so that was that was definitely annoying
for him and now
we see nbl missed his first one over
there too but but yeah
no that those are the ones that come
back to buy you and right now we've got
a dead tie here 39 a piece with less
than a minute
and this puzzle is annoying this puzzle
by the way you have to be
there's a king issue again this one's
tricky there it is
there it is
so we see we see in that one there
that hikaru made an error
based on the king the placement of his
king on defense
he did it twice now is that something to
read into
where he makes mistakes not not quite
but
we see that when it's just a kill puzzle
when it's just going
destroy he sees instantly right that
kind of puzzle can slow him down
no it's a great point and we see by the
way mbl still solving with five
nope now no time left but he makes it to
regaining five total we'll call it
puzzle points
uh against icaru as he won that one by a
spread of five so
so you know he carries still seaming in
the driver's seat like you said
maybe he needs to put his foot back on
the gas there with uh with uh
with that round but um but mvl strikes
back and on the scoreboard
we actually see that it's tied two games
a piece or two rounds a piece with
with hiccaro having the two puzzle lead
uh total they're 16 to 14
as far as the difference between them if
you don't mind can you pull up that
puzzle that he can't
miss that last one yeah let's do it i'm
there
right so in this position he played rook
d2
yep and bishop check on
on g8 was played so in here
i'm actually surprised he missed this
one because
by taking the bishop which is what he
did he allowed
the idea of queen f7 check
you can actually make the move so he he
took this piece
which now he allows a typical pattern
that he knows in his sleep
this check king h7 it doesn't matter if
you go to h8
right he's gonna check and it's gonna go
f8 f7
all day it's just a draw right so he
allowed this what he had to do was play
king back to h8
and force the knight to displace itself
and that's prob and that's what mvl was
able to do and find that solution
so in this position you have to go back
to h8 and force the knight to displace
itself with a check on f7
this is not what you want to do here and
now you can start checking
with with white the first check and your
second check with queen to h8
but after queen h8 king to g6 there are
no more checks 95 of them by queen
takes on e5 and that solves the puzzle
so i'm that one i'm actually surprised
he kind of missed
that one is you could you could see the
queen of seven queen f5 pattern right
and so for him to take means he was
somewhat distracted
but it's funny because obviously mvl won
the won the line but if we go to mbl the
right side it's actually one of the few
that nbl missed too so for whatever
reason that pattern
you missed that one too yeah for
whatever reason it caught them both by
surprise
and we see mvl's red x he he got
he got this same puzzle wrong and i
admit i wasn't following it in real time
maurice i i don't know if he missed it
with the same move but i'm gonna guess
he did
and and that he also failed to see to
see just the the drawing pattern so
funny stuff
you saw we saw carlo kind of say there
at the end that he felt panic because of
the time he was like i thought there was
20 seconds instead of 40 seconds so i
knew i needed to push and
that's a big part of this right is
knowing the clock management making sure
they don't miss tactics that they should
otherwise get
so well given
danny your point you just made is a
really good one given
10 seconds given five seconds you can
look and say
wait the guy has this check okay and
then the pattern just comes in your head
once i saw queen f7 the rest was easy
right
once i just got like why are you taking
the bishop right
but when your clock is ticking
my clock's not ticking i'm just chilling
talking with you about puzzles so it's a
lot easier from the side
for sure and uh and well we're gonna
have a close finish here at least in a
couple of these matchups right we know
we know ray robson
is doing his thing we've seen uh
demetrius a lot of poulos
doing doing his thing is the two seed is
there is there rematch of last year
inevitable or will someone disrupt it
but uh
if you're just tuning in don't go
anywhere this is the puzzle battle world
chess championship you can watch on
youtube and twitch chess tv and thanks
for being here
all right the next rounds are beginning
we've got hicario and nbl
queued up i'd say we stay right here
with these two household names
one of them is gonna go one of them is
going home right now
and here we go we have on the right we
have the old puzzle though we're not
queued up on
mvl's puzzles so we need to see what's
on the right
oh yeah yeah yeah that's a that's a
weird issue let me i'll give it a hard
refresh and that'll
that'll bring it up there we go now
they're both synced oops it switched
tabs though
we've got uh we've got a couple
technical difficulties here
jeffrey jiang and hikaru are not playing
each other
that's a good bug to note um
i'm going to try to find the match up as
jeffrey zhang and
donya are playing each other wow the eu
lot of provost matchup is also very
close but okay
we'll need to redo the uh we'll need to
redo i'm just going to go do it myself
we'll go find it in the watch tab and
bring up picario and mdl
and restart this thing if i'm glad
you're in charge of this because i would
the fans would be sitting there for 30
minutes if i was trying to figure it out
yeah well i'm gonna i'm gonna switch
over here to zhong and naradiski because
we can't seem to get that one
the hecaro mbl match up but okay
um all right this was a close one as
well
uh it looks like it looks like jeffrey
has the big lead right because he's up
three to one in the match
but the score is very close
this score done is coming back which
unfortunately
it might be too little too late let me
try one more time to find the hikaru
match
see if we can get this thing working
there we go 38 34
took a little bit of bouncing around
so but but this well we need to see the
score at the top there we go yeah we've
got 39.37 oops
car was shaking his head in frustration
we we never know what that means exactly
but he's gotten one wrong you got one
wrong early
mvl got one wrong early look at this
number 41
to 40 42 to 41. they are
whipping out the tactics and now he
carried with the slight two-point lead
and and mvl getting his second strike
that's huge psychologically there right
the fact that uh
oh hikaru has the second part as well we
just saw
flash up this is anybody's match right
now
somebody does not want a blunder with
only 20 seconds left
this is what has come down to look at
this weird tactic where the rook is
getting trapped
with knight e6 and there's a fork no
matter whoa what
b3 wow i have no idea how that puzzle
ended
but incredibly hicaro gets it mbl is out
with three strikes and hikaru hikaru is
going to be moving on
to the semifinals with just by the hair
on his chinny chin chin
that was a great battle between the two
of them
and that puzzle you see this kind of
puzzle this is the one you hate to have
in puzzle rush
one this is one of the types i'm going
to tell you straight up
hate to have because for me i love it
this is something you could
be instructive and show you maybe on my
twitch stream
not a regular tactic position this is a
study
how do you trap the rook yeah this is
nuts
yeah this is so annoying you know the
rook is the problem
but how do you do it exactly this this
is correct
this is correct i think knight e6 has to
be the move because otherwise rook at
five happens
yeah i think it was an error on the
board to yeah because it had to be this
and then the point is it takes here we
have a fork
yep look at five we have a four night
square rook
that that that the correct move
looks to be f4 after rookie five
yeah and then
and then on here that's where the puzzle
ended the final move is b3
get out of here b3 and black
is in zug's bomb look at this
unbelievable you're not threatening king
f3
it's the fact that black has no move
black has no move that's that's a
beautiful
finish b3 and black can't play king d7
or king f7
because of the forks on either side and
the rook is trapped
black can't push the g pawn because
you'll take up assad
and you're still in zug's bomb that's
crazy
again if king f7 knight g5 if king d7
knight c5 this is one of those
geometry lessons this is one right out
of the grand master maurice ashley
playbook right i mean this is like i'm
telling you this
this is what my stream comes to expect
something nasty like that
and it's all about seeing your
opponent's possibilities
not about seeing your own and here mbl
try to
bully his way to the finish which is
what you do when you want to finish off
a tactic
but he left the e1 square open for the
rook and that
i mean that's extraordinary idea and to
think that that's the only way for white
to win this position that's the other
beautiful thing about it
you got to give up your g pawn chaser
rook to the open board
and then in the last move play b3 and
cut off its one escape square
you hate these in puzzle rush that's
like seriously
what kind of people saw these were the
kind that we were solving in puzzle
survival on tuesday which felt a lot
calmer because you had time to you know
to make sense of it all right but yeah
again
mbl's puzzle battle world championship
goes home
on the move king of three everybody if
you're just tuning in rather than the
move b3 which again you can hardly hold
it against the man so
all right where did we finish after
round one who's moving on
this is our bracket ray robson with a
measly
50 point uh victory no you know
whatever not a big deal um
oh my god yeah it's he's good and eric
hanson is one of the you know he would
he would wipe the floor with me
um i'm not sure i've ever lost 10 in a
row i.e um
signed the adoption papers but he's very
good so that tells you what ray is
capable of as a puzzle specialist
hikaru goes to the semifinals by a four
point spread over mbl
demetrius latapulos not quite ray robson
numbers but
but pretty a pretty big difference there
of course sometimes sometimes it feels
unfair to look at it like this to a
youngster like christopher you maurice
right where he obviously is is very good
in the end it looks like oh man that
that wasn't good right
i'm sorry i have to object i have to
object demetrius's numbers
uh look fabulous
i mean his top score was 57 just like
ray his bottom score was 58 was 48 okay
one less than rey but then compared
their other scores i see 254s
i see a 53 where ray only got a 51.
i think their total is just a hair's
breath apart
in terms of total puzzles well and i'll
also a different view on that scoreboard
look at christopher u's numbers if
christopher had played
almost anybody else in the first round
he might have been moving on look at
those numbers
except right exactly the reason why you
see that differential
at the top is that eric didn't perform
to christopher used
level i mean christopher you versus eric
would be total domination
by christopher easily so that's why it
looks more competitive
but to meet demetrius and rey again if
we add up those numbers i'm gonna say
that they're almost i mean it might be
just i'm gonna say three points off for
ray i'm going to say
ray was maybe plus three and then the
closest match which we did cover
we did cover closely a couple of times
but obviously there was a lot of star
power in that round so we apologize if
donya and jeffrey didn't get the love
they deserve because wow
that was the match up that that uh looks
like it could have gone either way
with jeffrey just that much more
consistent right just a couple more
consistent in a couple rounds
and that's why mr zhong sends dania
nerodisky home although
i believe donya is still streaming so if
you guys want to head over to twitch.tv
slash gm nerodisky
and give him a follow he'd appreciate
that all right so where's our bracket
before we take our first break of the
day
we've got ray robson versus hikara
nakamura omgs are snaps i don't think
we're going to be focused anywhere else
in the next round
and of course we've got demetrius and
jeffrey so i know i mean i don't mean
that in a bad way demetrius and jeffrey
also a very very
powerhouse matchup but hikaru versus rey
can
nakamura uh stand up to the beast we we
know that it's
a difficult thing but hikaru has said
many times ray is the best puzzle solver
in the world and i think hikara will
will give us a show but but that's going
to be a tough uphill battle
for the uh the creator of the year in
2020 so all right don't go anywhere
maurice and i will be right back with
more puzzle battles
on today's show and uh we'll be back in
just a few minutes
[Music]
so
and we're back moved on to the semis we
are thanks yoda for showing up
apparently i'm going to say it that way
and either way we've got grand master
maurice ashley here
we're doing the best we can to just not
fall out of our chairs as these amazing
puzzle specialists and
speedsters blow us away with chess.com's
puzzle battle world championship
maurice you made some amazing
observations at the break so let's bring
up the scoreboard
that we had you you noted that not only
did christopher you put up the kind of
score
that would have had to move on against
almost anybody else but demetrius was
actually more consistent than ray in a
lot of ways if this does end up being a
rematch of last year's final
well i have an explanation but if we
just look at the raw numbers it's
different
if you if you had the battle happen
between demetrius and rey
round one 57 the ray 54 to demetrius
ray wins round two 56-48 ray wins round
three
57 to demetrius 54. demetrius wins round
four he wins
and round five he wins he would have won
three out of the five rounds we would
have made an extraordinary comeback
three to two against rey the total score
however raised up
two points what happens there that's
something i'm glad you asked that
because we mentioned it earlier and
um and i i i
didn't didn't have the full information
at the time so the scoreboard is meant
to reflect
the total difference between between um
every round so actually ray would have
won
despite demetrius scoring or let's say
winning three out of two rounds it's the
total amount of puzzles solved
the only reason we saw a 10-0 score at
some point is because for competitive
balance
and to prevent a runaway if rey wins
let's say by 22 in a round
he's capped as having only one by 10. so
the way it works is every puzzle matters
and that's super cool
because as we dive in right now to the
next round and we've got ray and recaro
rolling
it means that even if you're out of it
maurice right
you see the guy at 54 and that's
frustrating because you're at 46 you
should still keep solving because every
puzzle counts in the end
so uh there are
it's like twin positions on both sides
it's barely any difference as i look to
the left and to the right
the puzzles look almost exactly the same
although
now all of a sudden it's not going who's
taking the lead on the right of the
screen
as you see the difference in the two
puzzles but but here's ray ray's back
it's crazy and what's where it's gonna
show the difference of whether hikaru
has it today right to shock the world
and send ray robson the defending
champion home
it's going to be in those late 20s
rounds because what ends up happening
so right there in the mid-20s ray is
still operating on basically
memory right and and hikaru has to start
solving it in a different way at that
point and that's usually where you see
it now that said
picaro is hikaru is doing his thing
right now but he did get one
wrong that's the other thing is rey
hasn't
from from what we can see has no
mistakes so
the pressure is on hikaru with a bunch
of time left 142
left on the clock and you see that a
second error has occurred and now the
pressure
is completely on because a mistake now
and he could
end up with a terrible score a third
mistake
is a horrible score so you see he's
pausing he doesn't want to get stuck on
like 30 and ray racks up some 50
something number
and just blows him with a plus 10 out
the water right away so this is why you
see
hikaru can't see it look at his face he
is definitely not wanting to move
and that has allowed ray to take a
three-point lead well not
the car was back in business well let's
let's listen in to akara we know he's
streaming and see what his thoughts are
as he tries to keep pace with uh the
reigning puzzle battle world champion
ain't gonna be much talking now yeah
this is tough
nice he finds the mate although suddenly
i look over to the left i've got two
wrong which makes us really unpleasant
that's the point having already gotten
too wrong
and this one you got to worry about
those whites i mean i literally have no
idea what the
what is this exactly looks like there's
no
possible solution we're we're right
there with the egg
yeah what is this i i guess yeah to be
fair ray's having a bad run too so these
puzzles clearly are hard but what
yeah i don't even see how you could
possibly win this
yeah i mean no but rook takes oh the
queen's oh my god the queen's hanging
wow
all the yeah the queen yeah i didn't
realize the queen was hanging actually
oh that's pink yeah i didn't realize the
queen was hanging actually that's really
bad yeah
that was really bad that was really bad
i didn't see that either i was looking
for the wind
you look up boy you don't look back i
i'm right there with you i was sitting
there on the last puzzle and
focused on where's the mating net which
is kind of the thing that hikaru was
saying right is hey
right where's where's the beach
but the queen had been hanging for quite
some time the issue was
to just say save your rook
right you make this trade and then you
just take the queen and it's so funny
because sometimes
absurdly easy puzzle some of those can
hit you sometimes that
hurt because rey has taken a full 10
point lead
karu is feeling the pressure i don't
know as a brilliant player as
he is and he's a better chess player
than ray
well i'm sorry
but he did make a point that even ray
didn't put up his his mid-50s numbers
which we know he did several times the
last round in fact
i remember at one point we were
listening to a car oh and this is as you
and i have said this is this is hard to
follow all this but i was kind of
looking at ray's board
and he was stuck on like a low 30s
puzzle for a long time for him so
maybe it was something about the
delivery of those puzzles that that
caught both players off guard
um where they just hadn't seen him
sorry danny i forgot to mention
something because i said i had a theory
about how ray did
against against his opponent in the last
round against eric
you notice ray's numbers declined as he
kept playing
yeah the last round they declined he
consistently declined
as he kept playing and it's possible
when he realized
that he was dominating the match by so
much right that he
lost a bit of interest he was just like
yeah whatever i'm just gonna play real
quick and you see
that's why he threw in there like a 49
or a 48
i think that motivation matters so we
knew he was going to blow his opponent
out of the water he didn't need to keep
racking up the score so he probably just
was like whatever
here you see ray knows he wants to put
up big numbers
against ikaru early and you might see
the same thing happen if he starts to
dominate hikaru
then he might start declining as well
right
it happens right i mean it happens to
all of them because at that point if you
know you've won the match you know
you're
you know you've won the match right well
all right this one is not over yet we'll
see i
we know hikaru is capable of 49s and 50s
right we showed you his best puzzle rush
score in three minute
is actually 50 and against mvl i think
he put up at least 149
if not if not two um and so the oh wow
the next round has actually started i
was not aware of it and uh
and here we go we're at 29 to 26 with
nakamura
in the lead and two minutes remaining
all right well the problem for naka he's
got a 10-point
gap to make up so ray just has to do his
thing
every single round just just relax and
do his thing
and stay within one or two three points
of naka and they're going to be rounds
he wins
and there's going to be rounds that naka
pulls it off so i don't i don't doubt
that nakamura will be able to to win a
round
but is it going to be enough it's going
to be bi enough
the number has to be so big to make up a
10 point gap we see here
again two points but it's four rounds
that he has has to do it so here
four times three so that's plus three
and he just got one wrong
he just got one wrong and that caused
ready to catch up and now rey has
caught him and overtaking him you see
the 41 number but it's actually a slight
lead
as rey is just racking now and naka's
lost confidence
knocker doesn't know what to do here
he's frozen on a puzzle
and and look at ray just blitzed through
the darkness got two wrong now
this is almost unfair extraordinary
this guy ray robson is just a beast at
solving these puzzles quickly
49 to 42.
is this match already over the the
spread just gets so
big i mean this is why for those i think
you know there's a lot of fans that
follow this stuff both on
on on this channel and on hicaro's
channel maybe for the first time
seeing what what the world champion
puzzle solver which is who he is here on
chess.com as far as uh
our puzzle battles go what he's capable
of right this is not the same
chess you see where hicaru is capable of
of putting up an adoption against a guy
like ray in blitz and bullet right where
he could win 10 in a row
but in in puzzles the opposite is true
right
and wow ray again by the way look at the
carl's score 47 is a good score for
hikaru right if
we remember last round but but not good
enough against ray robson
no not good enough you've got to be
scoring 50s in order to beat a guy like
ray robson
if you're not cracking 50 you're not
going to beat him demetrius is going to
be the one who watch out for
as as he shows that he can get into that
number
consistently but again puzzle solving is
a very different
art you you people are better at things
in chess than others
you know danny you and i are opening
suck
but we could play some decent middle
games and we got
maybe average end games there's certain
things that we could do well
that could hit people but we can't do it
all well and naka
can't do it all well or at least can't
do it all on an
elite world-class top of the line level
like a ray robson yeah well it's funny
you know again we'll tell a story about
it because you know he's likely moving
on to the finals and
i think i shared this one last year um
when he
ultimately won it all but ray ray
several years ago maurice even before
puzzle rush i want to say when ray was
even 16 or something
his coach at the time alex anashuk
reached out and asked me
if we could put a little bit of
investment in increasing the number of
3000 puzzles in the database
because at the time and i literally
didn't i knew of the talent of ray
robson but i was like are you serious
he's like ray is memorizing your
database
and i want him and i'm like what are you
talking about he's like yeah
ray is memorizing the puzzles and i'm
like there's like
i'm like there's like 5 000 of them at
the time and he's like it doesn't matter
you've got to
anyway it was hilarious but that for i
think people just didn't know
how obsessed with puzzles ray robson was
until until some of this you know
some of the features here and he started
spending so much time blowing people
away
i'd be curious to know how he does on on
studies as opposed to these kind of
puzzles he's kind of tactical
how he would do on studies is it any
different
john nunn is this is a study solution
guy he's about the studies the unusual
ways you could win
right but ray sees straightforward
tactics in a split
second i mean the funny thing about ray
is how he always gets in time pressure
in his over the board games right i mean
he i mean we watch him all the time in
the u.s championship
and ray's the one you're going ray what
are you doing you're in time for sure
why are you are you looking for that's
been a story for ray since he was very
young i mean his trainers kaidonov and
anisha everyone said like ray
and it's something about a perfectionist
sort of mindset he has when he's playing
but in in this world
he he clearly trusts himself here
there's no there's no overthinking
things getting in time pressure when it
comes to puzzles
by the way look at his car though talk
about a round this is a round
now they're tied and rey is stuck
well honestly
ray cannot be stuck on this puzzle this
is i think he is
oh and he missed it that was that was
bizarre
that was bizarre i don't understand look
missing a puzzle is no big deal when you
realize you don't know the solution to
something
you just miss the puzzle go on just keep
going because you'll solve
other puzzles and you see there he is
back in business
he's at 40. despite having lost the
puzzle he's still
slightly ahead of ikaru as the numbers
are racking up with only 57
seconds left well we'll definitely go
back and check out what was an
interesting rook in bishop
versus rook endgame and it obvious it
stumped both players as we saw but
hikaru ultimately got it right
ray did not although as you said one
strike is no big deal
and reyes is still in control but but
shout out to nakamura of the three
rounds
uh maurice this is this has been the
closest and the best for hikaru from
start to finish
yes unfortunately only 30 seconds left
and
he he's not gonna be able to run up the
kind of must and he just missed one
yeah that hurts and then that's the
psychology of it when you miss one
you suddenly just cascade and now he's
gonna slow down because he doesn't can't
afford to miss another one
and here he's seeing his queen is
hanging and black's queen is hanging
what's the right way to play
and while he's frozen it's ray who's
just racking up the numbers
wow and there it is three in a row he
missed at the end
and very frustrated is naka as
this lead is insurmountable it's gonna
be a 27
point lead that this match is done
crazy that ray you know recovered the
way he did and he carries still putting
up good scores with a 47 remember his
all-time
three-minute puzzle brush bass best is
50. so these are good rounds but really
back in this position here so what
happened ray
played i want to bring up both both
boards
uh for some reason it's it's not letting
me throw both but either way
let's see what did hikaru get when he
played it he
ray played rook b7 i think what was the
move
i think it's i think it's
because you're gonna play
if you bring your rook back you threaten
bishop e3 check that forces
rook d voices the rook to go behind your
bishop
and then you play then you swing your
rook along the rank
the rook the king has to come it's cr
it's crazy we'd have to
i don't i don't know if our template is
set up for this i'd have to literally
click again and go to the engine room
and see what the answer is because
yeah but i this this is a but it looks
like it's it should be winning
easier i don't even understand why this
is a so
rook b7 is what ray played everyone but
this was wrong
even though i think the only move here
is rook
yeah no the only move is that when you
swing your rook as black to the other
side
then white is able to run to b1
and then you play rook yeah how it works
normally everyone is something like this
they try to run
again we uh i know this ending you want
the rook to be on the third rank the
white brook to be in this case on the
sixth rank
and you put your rook on the on the
fifth rank
that's the technical way of approaching
this i'm i'm breaking our template here
just for
just for a second here i know i know i'm
ruining the show but i'm gonna do it
because i have to know the answer
so apparently there's a number of moves
here
yes but that's why ray got it wrong yeah
this honestly looks like a bad puzzle
for us we got we need to remove this
because i've got the engine up
and it looks to me like black is winning
as you and i said maurice because you
and i know this pattern we're not these
guys but we know the pattern right you
move them
the only way to stop the thread
everybody is bishop e3 and behind them
yep and then you you swing to threaten
the checkmate the only way to avoid the
mate is to run
and then this wins every time so all
right
i'm i'm doing that because as always we
call ourselves out if it's a if it's a
chess.com problem
and that puzzle is getting removed that
was not a fair puzzle
shout out to picaro who's i guess
somehow luckily guessed the move that
the computer wanted
which was it was it rook b5 i don't know
but ray played rook b7 and you could see
the frustration on ray's face at the
time because he was like
he was like what are you talking about
right when he was here he was like this
is winning for black so anyway all right
well so you can't figure out what what
what car was it rook
rook b5 but only when the rook is on the
third
is it necessary to put the rook there
very interesting
that that is was indeed a mistake but
nevertheless
ray bounced back dealt with it and
now he's just he's just got to show any
number that's
fairly well no no it's over
mathematically it's over because
only 10 plus 10 is possible anyway
so the it's over the car we're just
playing for professional pride right now
100 and a minute kind of knew this
coming in he uh he actually wasn't even
planning on playing
in the final championship because puzzle
week has been rolling on this whole time
and and you know we were very aware that
the this bracket would would include a
lot of our puzzle specialists to bring
the fun to an end here
but we invited hiccaro and he accepted
you know he's uh which is awesome
because he knew the challenge was
probably
impossible to send ray robson home um
and
i think he even told me privately you
know when pigs fly but he did it anyway
and he knew so uh shout out to ikaro for
taking on the challenge knowing that
this was
this was probably not a not a feat that
he could pull off so
indeed but i'm curious about what's
happening in the other puzzles
any other matches uh can we pull up
those matches well no no
the nice thing in the semis is we're not
missing anything finally
this is the only match going on this is
the only match going on oh my apologies
i'm
not aware of that rule okay that's great
we get to watch these
uh directly so so yes
this is just a domination on his part
almost
ray could almost just blow anything
right now right just
lose both with ease so he doesn't have
to play anymore
send in the bench brain like crazy
look like just do whatever whatever
whatever doesn't matter how many i get
wrong whatever score
but he's not doing that and he car was
already blown three puzzles
and there we go
ray claims the win which is actually uh
just a polite thing to do because he
didn't need to keep running up the score
but i am going to observe that both
players missed this one
which was the the top of the third row
interesting i i didn't see which move
they played here everybody
but both players missed this particular
puzzle
here yeah it's white to move and win
i mean everybody in the world plays
rookie three in this position
yeah and i wonder if that's actually
what they did i have no idea
but okay interesting whenever they get
the uh what else could you
possibly play i mean it uh there's
there's no
there's just rookies okay
after rookie three it looks like the oh
the only try is king h8
i mean there is there is a potential f5
as well
that the puzzle might throw at you but
in this position it looks like uh rook
we have rook h3 why is this nice should
be winning right and the point everyone
is maurice is threatening knight g6 and
almost anything although maybe there's
some weird checks or something so
anyway apparently this was this was a
puzzle that
i would have gotten too because those
two moves are automatic like
up you're done you know what you know
what could be played there
f5 could be played rook f5
could be played against rookie three ah
oh back to the back to the beginning of
the puzzle
i'll bring it up the uh oh no but then
you still win you play
oh but you you can't because i thought
you could play no you better not check
that that would be a mistake
check the king moves and then you have
to find a move yeah
now you've got nothing actually right
this may be what happened you'd have to
you'd have to start with rook h3
you'd have to start with a tree danny in
that position
and okay yeah rotation then
so here you start with work h3 with some
kind of knight move throughout like
knight takes on f5
right and if queen goes back to g7 to
defend which is the main problem
now you can play rogue g3 right okay
maybe
maybe the slip happened right here going
too fast
yeah and they missed the sequence not
sure not sure what happened there was
no that actually makes sense and uh
again it's happening so fast that maybe
someone can clip it and solve the
mystery but
either way we've got uh we've got our
next
our next uh or i think the last round
between these two guys getting set to
start in a moment
um i think yeah
and uh yeah it looks like looks like
we're off
we no throwing in the towel
accepting the defeat graciously you
still keep solving
and can hikaru beat ray
at least one round everyone's rooting
for
one round we'll see what icaru can do oh
and ray misses one
that's big that's big if ikaru can win a
round he's going to be proud of himself
so can he do it he's leading right now
15-14
still a long way to go yeah we know what
ray does even when he misses puzzles he
he just keeps solving like he's like uh
finding dory right short-term memory
loss
and he just keeps swimming and keeps and
keeps winning
he's just a beast and don't put a
winning position in front of ray robson
he's going to find the solution
uh that was a that was a fun one but
hicaro's still oh
right as i said it i said the car was
still perfect and he missed
his 24th puzzle have
tied with how could they do 24 puzzles
with
in in one minute i mean a million i mean
it's extraordinary how
whoo blitzing through these and icarus
slowed down
slightly just a little bit but now he's
back now he's back the score is 29
29. this is tight right willy karu
pull off a last minute miracle
and he's ahead look at that he's up by
one he doesn't have
to watch but so does ray well this this
would happen if ray makes
any error along the way hikaru does pull
it off
so there are two ways to do it i'm not
sure if ray will make that mistake but
if ray messes up
and he's pausing right now both of them
are pausing
in this moment oh no no no no
missed it and he came out we saw him
kind of shaking his head like uh ray
figured it out
yeah again you know what's fascinating
ray's gonna rack up some number but
what's fascinating again
you see ray some of these puzzles and
you say well this guy must be better
than the other guy
and it's so not true it's so not true
chess is based on much more than just
puzzle solving skills
hikaru has other things a better
preparation
his nerves are stronger his endgame
technique is better
the things that that hikaru does better
that manifest themselves
in over-the-board chess game
or even in blitz or even bullet
you would think ray would kill hikaru
bullet given how quickly he sees
solutions
again guys this is a separate skill set
you have different things you need to do
well to manage
a chess game and i'm going to talk about
this later on my twitch stream
using puzzles to attack when you do that
you you sure you can solve the puzzles
but how do you get the good positions
how do you carry out the attack how do
you know how to wait
in positions delay moves because they're
not the right way to attack
you can't calculate everything but you
got to use your intuition sometimes to
be able to see
this is the right way to play and your
positional understanding this is the
right way to play
so these are different skill sets in
order to play chess well
but to solve puzzles you just gotta be
ray robson
yeah i mean and and it'll really be on
display as we get set for our next
i mean everything maurice just said as
we get set for our next match-up where
uh literally the the puzzle specialist
himself demetrius
not taking any way from ray ray's the
reigning puzzle battle world champion
but demetrius
not being a title player not even a
grand master none then i am i
don't even think he's a feeding master
and again that's not meant to sound
degrading at all it just really shows
you the separation between an overall
chess player's skill set
everything maurice just kind of went
through right and positional
understanding
and then what these guys are capable of
doing jeffrey zhang has quite the task
up ahead so don't go anywhere
we're going to take a very quick break
when we return our second semi-final
match-up between demetrius latapulos
and grandmaster jeffrey zhang we'll be
right back
[Music]
and we're back the second semi-final is
about to go down again demetrius lotto
poulos
versus jeffrey zhang uh before we jump
into it let's remind everybody of what's
at stake
because as we get even closer to
crowning uh a champion yet again
we are reminded that it's winner take
all so
more than ever it really really matters
to these guys and it was it was our way
of taking a look at this event
as a as a fun kind of uh you know
celebration of all that has been
chess.com puzzle week remember that
puzzles are free right now puzzle battle
is free normally a premium feature for
anyone tuning in
and uh for the for the puzzle specialist
a way to really keep them on the edge of
their seat and motivated to make it all
the way home
eight thousand dollars and uh maurice i
mean i know it seems a little brutal
right but you've done you know you've
done uh your uh your events that are
maybe not quite winner take all but
really put a lot of pressure on decisive
chess right so this is uh it's fun to
see an event that
only one person takes on all the cash
right yeah every once in a while you
want to see one of these events
but yeah it is brutal that you come in
you know you could win the kuching big
money
but that the competition is going to be
so fierce
and you saw ray robson do it against one
of the best players
on the planet in ikaro nakamura we'll
see can jeffrey jean conjects pull it
off
right now against all odds this is going
to be brutal
and i think the money is completely on
demetrius
at the moment and he's like you said all
in in being the best puzzle solver
in the world can he get that rematch
against
the man who has that and he wants it
right he definitely wants it
well um let's uh i think as the match is
getting set to start let's bring up the
last score
or the overall scoreboard um and show
again how ray did send
uh send his opponents home our our
previous previous matches there we go we
got our bracket
again hikaru uh took the challenge
against rey knowing that it was an
incredible incredible battle
and hats off to uh to hikara nakamura
for being willing to do that
kind of knowing ahead of time that you
know that the scoreboard was going to be
what it was
but ray does indeed move on so he is in
the finals and where we are is right
there
on the right side of our bracket who's
going to join right demetrius or jeffrey
we're finding out right now here we go
well let's be real this is going to be
rough
it's going to be rough we'll see i mean
a little solver
a puzzle beast
more than the last match i mean it
sounds weird to say because hicaro is
you know
super grandmaster and just you know
incredible the strongest player in the
field
i guess along with nbl right but but i
feel like this one does have a little
bit more of a chance because demetrius
is that much less consistent or at least
he has been historically than ray
and i think jeffrey spends a little more
time in the puzzle battle arena than
hikaru normally does but that said
i'm with you demetrius is obviously the
heavy favorite
i mean he's ahead right now 23 to 21 and
he is
whipping out these solutions just
absolutely impressive what he is doing
and you can just imagine
just how much training he does
on this and this alone jeffrey john is
trying to become one of the super grand
masters in the world
he's studying his openings religiously
he's trying to perfect his end game
technique so when he's
getting pushed to the limit by a magnus
carlsen he's able to defend those
those nuanced working pawn endings you
think demetrius is doing any of that
i don't think solving puzzles that's
what he's all about
let's solve puzzles although although
take a look take a look right demetrius
got the first one wrong
ray sorry not ray jeffrey is currently
up one puzzle so
i mean i'm with you and again i think we
kind of know the final we're gonna see
but
but i did have this one circled a little
uh look at that a second strike because
one of the things that we know demetrius
struggled with last year maurice was
was while he dominates puzzles and he is
an incredible puzzle specialist he will
likely make it to the finals
excuse me going against grand masters
is different than a lot of the people
he's battling against on a regular basis
right
he i mean he's a chess fan right so he
knows how good these guys are and i
think there's a psychological element
where we did see him stutter a little
bit where where he wouldn't normally
because
you have an opponent remember what these
guys are seeing is is the same thing you
and i are seeing so he's seeing
jeffrey at 42 right now right he's he's
he's seeing it
it's not only that the one thing i will
say is this
sometimes you want something so badly
yeah
that the pressure is on you and you just
and you feel the pain of that pressure
that the weight of that pressure on you
he wants this so badly he's been
training all year to get to this point
again
that it may be that it's it's just too
much pressure he's put on himself
in order to execute and you see there he
has
already lost his third puzzle so a bad
start for him
as jeffrey can add to the numbers and
jeffrey
messed up was not happy there plus four
to start with
look did you see demetrius get up and
walk around yeah
yeah he did he was frustrated but i like
that you said to me uh jeffrey was
unhappy there as we bring up that final
puzzle because
because he knows even though you got to
be happy with a with a four-point win
to start he knows he needs more than
that to send to me to send
gymnast98 username demetrius um his his
real name
to send jimmy's nine-eight home you're
gonna need more than a 47 score
um and so ray unhappy that he uh that he
did not solve this last one we'll go
ahead and i'll go ahead and
bring it up here and we'll we'll switch
over to our analysis
tab and uh okay got it a little
um so what was the answer let's go ahead
and analyze it jeffrey
right to move obviously has to take on
b6 i mean there's no
there's no check and he took a5 missing
queen a7 maurice instead of just
grabbing the bishop what a cruel puzzle
i mean i i don't know that that's that
cruel queen a7
is not that hard to see jeffrey jean
should spot it and the worst part is
if this i'm going to say something to
you right now if this was
in game again i want to make the
difference between puzzles and games
if this was an in-game situation
somebody plays bishop f6 you notice hey
you're attacking my rook on b2
and my other rook sitting on a1 that
bishop needs to go
so you're going to take it on a7 and let
the queen come in the way because
that threat is still on the board so
bishop f6
he should have noted that but in a real
game he would have easily seen that
no question about it and ripped the
bishop off and laughed at such a blunder
but because he's going so quickly
he's playing moves that just look like
they make sense and that cost him big
time
and we're going to go right back to our
next round of puzzles here
and uh i believe the players will be
getting started momentarily
look at demetrius look at demetrius he's
nervous
he this is if he doesn't win this when
does he get another world championship
chance
where right where nothing zero this is
he'll have to wait again for next year
guys
so he needs this he this is the moment
he's been waiting for
the pressure on him big time yep
and the next round is uh getting set to
start here
in just a moment and uh
and here we go we've got it up in fact
they're already they're already underway
again it happens fast around here in the
puzzle battle
championship um so
jeffrey takes a four point lead but not
a happy four-point lead because it could
have been more with that obvious
as murray said queen takes f6 miss but
at least it's a psychological
you know a good start for the the young
american super gm
and it puts pressure on on demetrius
which he seems to be responding to look
at this i mean he's
you talking about 20 puzzles in a minute
maurice he's on pace for a 25 spot
i mean he's dropping these puzzles right
now and they're ridiculous extraordinary
before you can even look at the board
the guy's already solved the puzzle
i'm i'm stunned by this by the way i'm
not
nearly as good at solving puzzles that
pace but he did get one wrong
he did get one wrong right there so he
has to keep going
with energy as jeffrey has
shown that he can he can stay there look
at that
almost tied almost still a two-point
lead though
and now they're tied and now they're
tied they are tied jeffrey just may be
a little bit behind in the puzzle but
still he hasn't missed right so there's
that now i don't think it makes a big
difference until that second strike
comes you made that that point earlier
which was a great one but
but also still jeffrey is he's still
perfect
and wow and look at that jimmis is
struggling with
puzzles earlier than he normally does
here in the mid 30s
yes again it's the tension he wants it
so badly he doesn't want to mess up
he needs needs more than anything and
here is jeffrey looking very cool this
is the jx we love when he's playing
over the board chest well he just looks
smooth cool
relaxed and in flow and right now he's
got that flow going look at him without
any errors flawless so far yep but
but jim is compounding he clearly found
a rhythm of puzzles he knew and now
jeffrey's the one feeling the heat
missing his first puzzle at 44. so
and this one's a big one look at jeffrey
paws jeffrey has paused
trying to figure out what the solution
was there meantime
demetrius galloped to head and has that
four-point lead so essentially the match
is tied and jeffrey just got his second
one wrong
phil it's now again it's a five-point
lead so technically demetrius is up by
one now up by two
we'll see if jeffrey can keep it close
and again this is why he was shaking his
head everyone in the last round because
jeffrey knew
a four-point swing was not going to be
enough to hold off demetrius
consistently and right now it's seven
points
i had eight points ahead just blitzing
out these solutions
and the battle is over an eight
point lead wow wow
yeah an eight point lead which means
he's up by four in the total match
because
again if you just tuned in jeffrey did
take the first one by four but
wow it's just crazy and i will say this
what we saw there
uh after this puzzle here that he got
wrong which was really almost just a
slip of a king and pun ending
missing this move blundering into a draw
where you actually trap your own king
and of course king to b6 was the win but
after that look at the run he put up
in those fourth and fifth rows i swear
when he hit these mid-40s puzzles
maurice
it was like he had seen all of these
before like that's how fast he was
solving them and that's where you start
to see the difference between
rey and demetrius and the others because
it was the opposite for jeffrey he was
actually still perfect and got that king
upon ending correct
that demetrius missed but then slowed
down big time in the late 30s early 40s
you know when you're saying a guy has
seen these puzzles before
and you have how many puzzles in the
database a lot
a lot it's at least 10 000 right
oh no no now it's i mean we're talking
hundreds of thousands total
um but um when you get into the smaller
rating groups just because of how
difficult it is to have a quality 2900
puzzle
we see even on shows like this we're
going to remove that rook and bishop one
later today right
that it it gets a little harder so it's
down to like it's probably like 50 000
puzzles to be honest but
i'm saying 50 000 puzzles and yeah he's
probably seen a lot of them before
how do you memorize 50 000 puzzles
that's ridiculous
that's ridiculous but and it means any
pattern as they play again
in this round and he's already up six
seven and three
by the way this is like neo in the
matrix man how do you move this quickly
it's it's ridiculous it's completely
ridiculous
there's other ways to memorize it too
and in fact hans neiman who played last
year kind of pointed this out and it's
you know it's kind of working the system
a little bit but he would spend time
in solving puzzles you can actually
click on the puzzle go to the analysis
board and see the puzzle id
that allows you to actually look up the
puzzle manually so if you really want to
invest the time
and that's what you want to do you could
spend eight hours a day and probably
make your way through thousands of
puzzle ids and and
get you know so again like you said this
is a specific skill
i don't think demetrius and ray are
doing that i think they're just solving
it um
you know comparing to what han said that
he spent some time doing but
but it is possible right and people
would say well why don't you fix that
hide the id moments we're like look we
don't need to fix that if someone's
going to spend that much time trying to
memorize the database then good for them
right i don't know what else to say well
let's be clear
you may say well you're not really
solving you are
memorizing uh listen chess is memory
a lot of a lot of chats is memory not
every not every aspect of chess's memory
but if if somebody studies an opening if
mvl comes
and shows you the night or and shows you
25 moves of theory
are you going to say well you shouldn't
do that either magnus comes in and
and shows perfect in-game technique
because he studied fundamental
chess endings you're going to say well
you shouldn't do that either i mean
sorry of course not right we study chess
and we learn things about the game
so that we can play better when the
situation arises so
it's not all memory a lot of this is
skillet solving
the guys are showing i was done and now
he's got a five point lead
it's gonna be very difficult for jeffrey
jeffrey like you said should have gotten
more points in that easy puzzle
so he had a bit of a padding this is
going to hurt him in the long run
well it shows that he also did enough in
that first round to kind of poke the
bear if you will
right and uh demetrius has woken up so
shout out to him because now he's
putting on a show
we're gonna definitely go back before
the next round starts and just look at
that puzzle number
id number five five two two two six in a
second maurice because
that's an example to me of where these
clearly seen the puzzle before you or i
like having not seen that puzzle like
how do you solve that so fast it was
insane but he did
and um although now while he's at 50 he
does have a couple strikes
so we'll see how this finishes in the
final 30 seconds you also you know it's
very important to recognize that
it's one thing to call it memory as
jeffrey has flamed out
at 46 and the number is just going to
get too big
for him to catch up at some point but
you got to realize
also as we see there an eight-point
lead so therefore 12 points overall this
is
very difficult now for jeffrey and two
50-point
numbers by the way 57 was that 57-54
so that's going to be competitive with
ray in the finals those are good numbers
to be showing
absolutely you can do that now you said
this puzzle
look at it how do you solve this puzzle
this was an example i want and again i'm
not it's not we're not throwing any
shade memorization itself is a big part
of chess and super difficult or whatever
but it just shows that
i was watching this in real time maurice
and he there's only one move you can see
the engine has only one move
that is not even quite plus four for
white it's very close and in a weird
game with a queen and
rook versus versus this like in a real
game
if white doesn't find rook 3 to d4
maurice maybe black is the one playing
for a win i mean it's crazy right but
white
but he found this move instantly played
this move instantly
and this move and then the puzzle was
over with bishop f6 and so to me
i don't think it's unfair to draw that
probably he's seen this one before
to find that idea so quickly so
precisely
well looking for in my eyes was not a
hard move is the the move that i looked
at first
but f6 to go away from everything
and play rook d6 next right and to do
that
instantly that
that's impressive i mean yes it's
clearly a strong move after you see it
but for it to be your first instinct
rook h4 gets discarded
and then you realize let me play rogue
d6 first before rook h4
right your mind should hesitate
somewhere
to just do it instantly that's very
well let's bring up our current
scoreboard again if you're just tuning
in we are in the semi-finals of the 2021
puzzle battle world championship here on
chess.com remind everybody
puzzles are free on chess.com today go
play puzzle battle
this is where we've been at ray robson
the reigning champion the defending
champion
send hikaru nakamura home uh demetrius
latapulos who played in the final last
year looks like he's about to do the
same to super grand master jeffrey zhang
and uh on that note we get set and uh
our next round is going to begin
here we go no scores you just put up
very important ray's last two scores
did not matter ray's last two scores he
first of all he resigned one of them
not resigned but he stopped it and
called it a win
he was up 10 and the very last one he
was already up eight so
the last two scores don't count if this
was a what
in the matches that count one two and
three
if this were a direct head-to-head match
with demetrius
i do believe rey would be ahead yes he
would be ahead because demetrius's
43 is not gonna cut it that would sound
that was a bad round to start you cannot
get 43 against ray robinson
and then you're between that match you
can forget it you're going to die so he
doesn't want to get numbers like that
ever or
to get it at the end when when the match
is already over which is not
going to likely happen with ray so
that's why we saw him get up
and walk around and be like look i
cannot be putting up that number
when i play the one guy i'm thinking
i've been thinking about all year
yep and now again he's oh look at that
speaking of a 25 spot in less than a
minute we have it he didn't quite do it
when i first pointed it out a couple
rounds ago but look at this 27 28
puzzles almost yeah just about 28
puzzles in one minute but look at this
one
and just a brief hesitation i thought he
was going to hesitate on it for just a
second and
that was that and jeffrey um
not too far behind him right oh no oh
and he messed up with knight
to f6 check on that last move
that's this is brutal it's just brutal
because it looked logical but this is
going to be the match
as jeffrey cannot move quickly anymore
if he doesn't know without without
absolute certainty
what the solution is and here i'm
surprised queen check and queen check
again looks winning
and he took a little while there did
jeffrey uh but
a five-point lead to annie yeah no it's
it's with no mistakes by the way
it's what we what we expected right but
i think as you said we're we're already
kind of talking about the rematch of
last year
whoa demetrius does miss one but overall
still in great shape um jeffrey has put
up a couple good rounds you see the
scores everyone 47
49 49 is a very good score
um it might even might even actually be
tying his all-time three-minute puzzle
rush score we'll bring that up again
um in a bit i forget
three minutes though okay so jeffrey
jeffrey jones best is 52 all the time
sorry maurice go ahead
52 all times is best yeah world champion
puzzle rush you need to never see 40
basically i mean
you just you've got to be able to hit
50s consistently
if you're playing for the money and you
see here 57 54 by demetrius
ray does the same kind of thing jeffrey
consistently will get in the 40s
but it's the 50s he needs to get in in
order to truly win
to truly compete not even win to compete
with the top players
man that last one that demetrius solved
with queen c8 being the final i i
brought you see my mouse over here
everyone i brought up because i just had
to see it again
the mini board of queen b6 and you take
the knight
never mind we'll bring it up but that
was just i'm blown away um all right
they're done so i'm just gonna
i'm gonna click on it and uh and bring
it up
to our uh to our analysis board here as
you and i get set because
so this patch is over this match is over
yeah one round left
only a 10-point swing is possible and
he's already up what is he going in with
plus 16 i think
yeah he's up he's a big time and not to
say that once this position is reached
it's not obvious
queen to c8 because because frankly it's
the only move for the queen right if
you go to c6 then the bishop b5 pins you
but it was just the speed that he solved
it with that he had seen the
seen the puzzle before it felt like it
was just bananas to me so anyway
all right we'll bring back the
scoreboard sorry i just had had to show
that and entertain my
my fan my fan-ness the fan in me that is
just blown away by these guys
and there you go it's a 20-4 overall
score
a um a 20 point lead right now for uh
or sorry 16 point lead overall for
demetrius
yeah this is this is just too much
but look at rey's numbers and compare
them to icarus numbers
i mean ray not ray jeffrey's numbers
excuse me jeffrey would have
dominated hikaru in the head-to-head
match
with these numbers well and that's why i
said what what i said in regards to
and as the next round kicks off we'll
bring it up as we're talking about it
again
i didn't mean it as any shade torre car
who took on the champion's task of
knowing
knowing uh that he you know wasn't going
to win this event right but he wanted to
do it anyway and have a chance to go
against ray
but i i thought this match would be
closer and demetrious is a little bit
less consistent than right at least at
this time that ray has been the world
champion
and jeffrey spends more time in puzzle
battle than hicaro does so i
i had the thought that jeffrey might be
a guy that could shock us but as it
turns out he's not going to shock us but
he is putting up a score that as
marie said would have sent hikaru home
so
again you're not throwing shade
hikaru knows it yeah he knows it's not
about solving puzzles quickly that makes
you an elite player
it it's about all the other things that
are involved
and he has that package you want to be
well-rounded as a chess player
you cannot just solve puzzles and think
you're doing something
anybody who sits around and solves
puzzle rush only all day
and and think that their rating is going
to get any higher well think again
so yeah that's that's not throwing shade
at anybody hicary has enough accolades
and his ability has been proven time and
time again
for him to know that if he sat down
against demetrius he would destroy
demetrius in the chesapeake bay
demetrius may not win one game in a 20
literally not one in 20 despite all this
clear tactical prowess
that he has so it's a different skill
set and he's showing that he's a
boss at solving puzzles that's
that's we'll see if jeffrey can do what
hicaro did higaro gave us quite the
quite the race in that last round um
but ultimately still fell short to ray
but here
jeffrey might be about to take home the
last round
between these two it's close
we still got over a minute to go and the
harder puzzles coming this is where
the difference will be seen one look at
this he's up four
yeah he's up by four now only two but
still
he seems to be in a good rhythm right
now jeffrey we we got both their eyes on
camera
he is alive as soon as we set it close
the gap to one and has now
tied it up seriously 43 jeffrey has to
stay consistent
he cannot mess up and here he's paused
pause for justice oh wow he did solve it
and demetrius missed his second
majors missed it
wow what a close finish here in the last
round 30 seconds to go
what will happen will jeffrey just
bragging rights at least yeah a little
bit of bragging rights
show what he can do and he has done it
he has done it he just missed another
puzzle
jeffrey takes a win now can he get in
the 50s will he be able to get
a 50 spot he didn't get it any of the
rounds so far here he goes
come on jeffrey get a 50. there you go
get it puts puts up the 5-0
you got it he's got 51. one less than
his best score ever
you needed more of those though to be
competitive wow
no that was a great a great score 51 for
jeffrey zhang his
his not quite his best all time but
right there
well congratulations to jeffrey it was a
good run unfortunately as we've said
it's winner take all
and we will have a rematch of last
year's championship
which we'll break into and uh and start
to preview and talk about here after our
final break before ray robson and
demetrious lot of poulos throw down in a
rematch
of the 2020 puzzle battle world
championship so
we got 10 000 of you on twitch we've got
i don't know
don't have in front of me on youtube but
no matter where you're choosing to watch
from thanks for being here
we will be right back with the final of
the 2021 puzzle battle world
championship
in just a minute
[Music]
so
and we are back getting set for the
finals here in the
puzzle battle world chess championship
but before we get into that a big
big shout out want to remind everybody
to head over to twitch.tv
gm ashley i even just i just typed the
the command in our twitch chat i'll do
it again
just there we had about 2600 of you on
youtube
you should also be subscribing to
maurice ashley's youtube channel
and follow him on twitch because uh
because big things right
i'm not going to tease things that are
coming to your channel soon with some
awesome special guests you have coming
but i'm going to say big things from
maurice ashley's
content creation online this year right
indeed indeed we got a lot of stuff
coming it's going to be fun
it's going to be interesting it's going
to be informative though that's the most
important thing
of all you know i like to teach danny
that's been
a part of my personality my character my
mo
for decades now and that's what we're
gonna do so we're gonna talk some
serious
slashing attacks some vicious attacks
with one specific theme in mind you're
gonna see
in this day on today's show so right
after this one
i'm gonna give an extra shout out going
off script here because i'm just gonna
say that i personally am a huge fan of
the way maurice delivers his content
because he puts so much work into it and
again
he's not joking when he says he likes to
teach so much stuff there is literally
if you're if you're on twitch and you
know you've been watching
all kinds of other chess streams this is
not like other chess streams you are
going to get better
watching these shows and maurice breaks
it down like
i guess like a pro like we would expect
of you and you know who else is puzzle
pro
ray robson let's remind everybody what
they're playing for here maurice
eight thousand dollars is on the line
man winner
no second place prize it's it's cruel we
know okay and uh but it's happening
and it's gonna be awesome brutal
um let's remind everybody of just how
close we expect this to be here
everybody in this particular eight
player knockout today
was awesome we know that uh and they're
putting up scores that you and i
couldn't touch
but ray robson and demetrius lotapulos
at the top with their best three-minute
scores being 69 and 68 respectively
we haven't seen anyone touch 60 yet
today maurice but i will say
last year there was one round where i
believe both rey and demetrius got in
the 60s in the puzzle battle
wow well they should be able to pull it
off but
look they knew they were going to
dispatch the competition in the first
couple of rounds like
you guys got to go but it's now they
know this is it
they're playing again it's the world
championship and it's on
and they're off and they're off right
now they're already at a nine and ten
score for those of you think hey
you were late where'd you go remember
these guys are solving puzzles in like
five
they were pretty much at ten in like
five seconds so uh we you haven't missed
much
at least as far as the eye can see and
wow maurice this is it
1515 deadlock you can if you take like
the abstract viewers you know where you
like you back up and you make your eyes
look at the whole thing
like they're out they're on like the
same puzzle at the same time right
and it's it's wild to see the indeed r
and ray just
just came back and took a small
millisecond lead
at the moment they're at 22-22 this is
just the best of the best in the world
at solving puzzles showing what is done
at this level it's incredible look at
this you can just look at the score and
see
how close it is no error so far and as
soon as i said that
he messed up and you saw him wince right
there
did demetrius when he finally made a
mistake and that mistake has cost him
a number of seconds and rey has taken a
big lead
at this level of three points yeah and
he's got
a four four point now with one strike
also
against uh gymnast9's credit and we see
ray is still
again i don't know if it's memorization
pattern recognition memory doesn't
matter what he's put in the time
and you see it you see it right here
he's uh he's solving like he's seen
these things before
but he's also happens to be a height
almost 2700 feet a player so
he doesn't need to have known it only he
also
is a boss of a chess player and he's the
world champion when the world champion
puts pressure on you
you cannot let his will that's the
imposition
of his will on your brain and that is
what is happening right now is he's
got this six point lead that he's not
giving up five point lead now a second
mistake by
demetrius and he's made a third cracked
at that moment
this is terrible because rey can rack
up a massive score and get a 10 point
lead in the first round you see
demetrius is walking around he is
disgusted that he got a 41
in the world championship that is not a
number you want
no it and you said it you said it best
because it's not even that he lost it's
the 41
number right it's the fact that that's a
score
that oh and ray ray misses his first
there but that's a score that
you just you can't get you can't get in
the finals um as you said it's got to be
50s or go home
and even with ray missing one he's still
going to put up a mid 50 score here
uh in the final seconds yes and well
he's only going to get plus
10 not not plus whatever he can rack up
but he's showing this is almost
psychological hey
come take a look at the number i'm going
to put up on you
yeah you got to do this 56 a
brutal start for he's got to hope
demetrius
does that ray messes up along the way
because this could be over from this
very first round yep
and you said it it will be capped at 10
that's the way the rules work so if
that prevents it from being a
competitively unbalanced matchup if it
ends up being a landslide i don't expect
this to be the difference between these
two guys all day everyone but let's uh
let's bring up our scoreboard as i'm
going to bring up
the only puzzle that ray got wrong in
that
very very impressive run of 56 i believe
his high of the day
has been has
but yeah so this this was the one he got
wrong i didn't see it in real time
maurice do we know which
what move he guessed here that was wrong
the best move is knight to d2 which
by itself is just absolutely crazy in
this position
what is going on here i mean absolutely
just outrageous
that like that makes that move makes
exactly zero
sense why would you give away your queen
on a three
look at this full combo where he's 92
takes and then queen d6 is is this one
i mean that's that's unfair yeah of
course it's just unfair like what is it
that's
amazing by the way by the way you're
threading the rook
but it's not clear what else you're
threatening because queen g3 is not a
threat queen h2 is not even mate
yeah so so you're so the king is going
to go for a walk and
eventually you made it in three moves it
looks like yeah it's made in three yeah
the full combo i i believe uh ray did
not see queen d6 everybody i think he
found knight d2 but the full combo is
actually rook f3 and then queen h2 which
apparently
will win the rook on the next move so
all right mind-blowing stuff
we get set for our next round of these
two guys which uh
which will be underway shortly but um
wow wild stuff there in that puzzle i'm
look i looked at that puzzle i thought
it was rook g1 and queen e5 but there's
a queen on e2
that just goes to show how crazy the
puzzle was
and how easy it is to mess up in that
position i mean just
that's a ridiculous puzzle you got two
queens on the board and you got a sack
yours on a3 so you can play queen d6
what was that a 4 000 puzzle
yeah no it's nuts all right well now
it's on jimmis he's down by
10. in total it was even worse than that
15 as we saw a 56-41 score there for ray
robson but
all right the next match begins right
now and we'll see
if demetrius lotta pulos can bounce back
he's gonna he's gonna try to put up his
best number that's all he can think this
it could be over right now
if he doesn't win this one or if rey
adds to the score
you're in deep trouble like absolute
deep trouble
but the the key for him is just to stay
consistent
as consistent as he can say and the hope
that somehow rey messes up
let's be clear if rey doesn't mess up
this could be done already
yep well remember unlike the uh
quarterfinals
let's say the the initial round of eight
and the semis this is a
10 battle matchup so we've been seeing
five
match up sorry five round match up so in
the finals here we're going to give
these two guys
10 total chances so um so
let's let's remember that everyone don't
go anywhere right we can see these guys
slip and slide and we know that in some
ways maybe not quite like bullet
necessarily maurice
but we have seen momentum be a thing
right so sometimes
you know you start off wrong but if you
find it
it's like it's like everything clicks so
we'll we'll see what demetrius can do
and maybe find his rhythm here uh before
he lets ray run away with it
again i'm going to argue if rey if rey
doesn't mess up
it's just ray is ready the battle is
just so
close look at the number ray has now 30
to 29
it's a close score ray could just stay
with him the whole time
right and win some lose a little bit
here you need
rey to start blundering ray needs to go
down
if reiki's being ray 10 points
is just too much so great did make a
mistake
oh but as soon as i said it uh
it's funny they both missed that puzzle
and that just shows you the way that
they approach these things guys
we'll take a look at this puzzle when
this round wraps up to see what they
both missed but um
it shows you that most the time they're
both seeing puzzles they know and that
was clearly one that maybe
maybe uh neither one has had in their
book yet
this last one they also hesitated just a
little bit but now they're both at 36
a close score here 37 37
and it looks like demetrius is taking a
slight lead yes he has
he's a little bit ahead in the solving
as he's going ahead
just by one he needs for his ego
for for confidence he needs to win
a match quickly and this is one that he
has a chance to win
yeah and he's uh he's got three and
both sides seem to be struggling with
this series of this is definitely
going to be a lower score than we just
saw no matter what everyone
something about this round which does
happen because the algorithm is
delivering them
randomly something about this round has
clearly been harder for them
than maybe their previous um their
previous sets
i'm sorry danny did you see the comeback
that ray made i know that was nuts
like that he blitzed by him and a third
error
with time running down and ray able to
rack up
a three-point lead just at the buzzer a
three wow
extra and we celebrate
already give a head nod there maurice
and uh
the uh the big cam shows he he gave like
a head it was almost like a
yup i got this and and while we see
these two guys on camera i'm gonna bring
up
two positions for us to look at both the
one that they both missed
and then this absolutely nutty one that
um
not sure if you saw it in real time
maurice i'm gonna go to that one first
this is a good example of crazy puzzle
memorization
at least as far as how quickly he played
it it's not just that he finds
the move rook rook f1 but then he
instantly already knew the puzzle that
the only winning move is rook eight to
f5
like you gotta i mean i would be looking
at other things and he played this
instantly because now there's no way to
deal with check
and mate on the h file and you have to
play it in this order
that is ridiculous i'm gonna tell you
right away you don't play that move
instantly yep
that's really crazy so that's an example
and that was a by the way i think that
was his number 47 being solved everybody
so that's
that's again that's that's crazy hard
crazy memorization then the one that
they both got wrong
i'm finding it was this one right here
and i actually didn't see what both
sides missed
but rook takes b2 is the move yeah
so they must have both oh actually i
remember at least one of them now played
queen takes a2
so that was the move they missed you
have to play rook takes b2 because after
that it's an easy puzzle the computer
just gives away its queen and
they wouldn't have missed that so it was
this move here that they played queen a2
i'm going to say to you i'm going to say
to you that
rook takes b2 is instinctively bad
why because your bishop on b7 on g7 is
pinned
yep and maybe it might be captured so
instinctively it's bad
but of course it's good nobody's gonna
take on g7 it's a queen you're giving up
that's dumb
so you you might hesitate just for a
moment
wait i can't take because my bishop is
pinned or somebody might knock the legs
out from under my rook
turns out it's all secure you don't have
to worry about anything just take the
pawn you're crushing the player
they have nothing to do to address your
bishop on g7 the rook cannot go to d7
because c2 will hang to mate so
no problem there and can you believe
this easy puzzle
is what these great jobs and it's funny
and it shows that they both missed it
right so as we as we get set here for
our
we're going to get the third round
rolling but yeah they both missed that
puzzle which just shows you they uh
they didn't know right they haven't seen
it before now that'll be added to the
old uh the old whatever insane memory
they apparently have
and right right before danny when you
think about it because
because for taste beats it was a move
you and i would play in a heartbeat like
give me the pawn
it's free and it's not even it's not
even the black isn't better there which
makes it even harder right
it's the puzzle is a good puzzle rook
takes b2 is the only winning move but
but it's an easy move to make queen
takes a2 so crazy
and and they will they will learn their
lesson together on that one but
all right ray is up by 13. closer match
it was it was only a three-point spread
there
but he can't keep that up demetrius has
to start winning
and i'm going to tell you he's got to
win now he's got to win now
he cannot let ray add more points to
this score it's just gonna be too hard
to come back
unless rey gets super tired or something
but i don't
see it ray could play these for hours
and he does and it's it's why he is who
he is and why he's about to drop like
demetrius another
25 spot in the first minute which is
crazy and it was funny shout out to ray
because we had some emails back and
forth when you invite
when you invite the reigning and
defending world champion to something
and you've changed the format to be
winner take all puts a lot of risk on
them right
and so shout out to ray that he was like
yeah i'm game so he was that confident
he was like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
negotiate for anything like i'm game
even though you guys change the format
where i won't get anything for second
place
so uh it's gonna be fun here to see how
these two finish in the next seven
rounds
i like that that's great that's cause
that's called swag i got swag
swag and i'm not worried about who
money whatever i'm the world champion i
want to go
i got game and let's get it done right
now he is getting it done although each
one of them has made a mistake
looks like on the exact same puzzle
again again
on the exact same part we'll have to
bring it oh and ray makes a second
mistake
so this puzzle here that i've got i'm
highlighting here on the mini board
maurice and i will bring it up um in
between the break of rounds and take a
look because
again it shows you how similar how just
why these two guys
have to have the best all-time scores in
three minutes 69 and 68 respectively
yeah their hair's breath apart and they
see similar patterns this is what puzzle
geniuses do
i love these puzzles i'm seeing flash in
front of me and
he's got the three-point lead but we've
seen ray just make a three-point lead
look like no point lead if you start
messing up and two mistakes
this is a lot of pressure by the way on
demetrius he's got two mistakes
he knows he cannot afford to make
another one but ray
also has two mistakes and ray is stuck
not moving at all because he doesn't
want to look at that
and and ray didn't make it
his reaction with your voiceover was
perfect he was like what am i doing i
mean obviously it's a big win
because he's up by seven 46 to 39
but he had a chance to run the score up
yeah let's bring it up right there
um i'm gonna bring up the last two
puzzles the one that he missed and then
the one that they both missed
it very important to win so that's a big
deal he shouldn't feel bad
but he the very important to win we had
to do it
sooner or later only getting 39. is ray
getting tired
that's an opportunity for demetrius
but let me just say if he had won if he
had done the 10 thing because it doesn't
matter how much he hit it's still 10
he would have only been down three now
he's down
will will that haunt him later yep
yeah absolutely well let's see what he
missed here um in this position
he played rookie eight now the winning
move is rookie eight but i don't think
he played that
oh okay i think he played queen of two
if i
and again it happens very fast so
forgive me uh fan but i'm pretty sure he
didn't play rookie eight
um i mean he may have played rook c but
i remember the final position was not
his work on eight and so i think he just
missed the
the first move here which again
understandably that's a very
it's a very hard move to see well
i i mean i i saw it
again i'm not on any pressure but i saw
the idea right away the back prank is
exposed
where do you put the rook to take
advantage of that and if you put it on
the c file
the queen can draw back to d1 and then
how do you deflect the queen
right wow then you can play queen f2 on
the second move
right right so that's why it has that's
a good point you pointed out that's why
it has to be rook e1 to point out
sorry rookie eight for everyone you have
to put the put the rook and queen
together on the f
on the uh the e1 spot which is why this
is the only
the only move order to go for okay well
but and then the other one
the other one excuse me that um getting
to it i had it i had it somewhere i
think it was right here danny
yeah that puzzle it's easy the reason
why it's also easy to mess up
and that last puzzle is after rookie
there is h3
aha and that actually was the that was
actually the main line
is is the combo is rookie eight h3
and now you got to find the queen in
this line with with queen e5 and rogue
h1 after g3 i mean yeah
that's that no it's understandable right
and and again the other one which is the
one they both missed everybody was this
with the answer being knight takes f3 g
takes
and bishop takes now when bishop takes
a6 you take d2
and you win here i actually i don't know
what they played
um i think that i think the move they
played was actually bishop c4 i saw one
of or no
maybe one of them took with the queen
but ultimately this is the only way that
wins
yep okay
oh man not not a hard puzzle that those
two puzzles are not hard puzzles
they saw much more difficult puzzles
than that like
light year is more difficult but at
speed sometimes that
sequence move order sequence will catch
you they're little things that catch
even the best people
and a little thing like the move order
will get you but here we go
can he ride that little bit of momentum
that he got
from that win and if he can see if he
can close the gap with ray in this round
yeah again everybody if you're just
tuning in where have you been
we got almost 3 000 of you again on
youtube almost 10 000 on twitch but uh
yeah
ray really won the first round big time
as you can see 56.41
but uh but it's not over we still have
seven more
rounds to go here in the 10 matchup
final
but this is great for demetrius the fact
that he has
won in commanding style
so and and he closed the gap in the last
round that was important
close the gap in in round two says i can
stay with this guy i just gotta stay
cool stay confident
stay calm i will make up ground
six points with ten rounds that's
nothing to make up
it's all about your confidence that gets
it done
so let's see if he can pull it off and
right now he's up a point
keeping the flow but it's a long two
minutes to go
agreed agreed agreed um in the uh
okay he's still up here in the in the
fourth round 27 25 although he's
looks like he almost got stuck there
nope he finished it made his 28th
but most of both of these guys are what
he does here he got stuck on that puzzle
now here's ray here's where with the
same puzzle
and ray paused for a second as well you
saw that yeah so
they pause on the same kind of puzzles
very interesting we should note that
anytime
somebody pauses will the other one do
the same
in that kind of puzzle look this one the
34th puzzle
he also paused i want to see when ray
gets to puzzle 34. here it is
we'll rate pause here yep and the same
thing it's incredible
and the same thing it's like twins they
think notice the difference 35
they both rattle off instantly so again
a lot of this is like
they've done the work right they've uh
they put the time in
a mistake and he reacted physically did
demetrius
and that has cost him in the next puzzle
as ray closed the gap
but it is it's not it's still three
though it's still three
can he maintain it it's a long 43
seconds left
and we see he still hasn't missed one
now he's on no
actually no he did just solve correctly
the puzzle that demetrius got wrong
but it doesn't matter he's still down by
three you got to speed up
gms98 is about to hit 50.
well speeding up is not he's keeping a
great pace he doesn't have to speed up
he's going to hope the other guy misses
but just keep a good pace
and the other guy might slow down
himself so here we have a two-point lead
16 seconds left can ray
make the spurt and it's 52-53 look at
the score
it's coming down the wire deadlock six
seconds one point
separating them one puzzle oh and
this is his last one but ray runs out of
time
all right well that was a boss round for
both of them
the first round where two players scored
both players scored in the 50s
and a big score that one of the best
scorers either has put up
so unquestionably look at demetrius's
trajectory though
he's getting stronger yeah ray had to
raise staying himself he had a one bad
round in round three
but demetrius can say look i'm catching
my flow
i'm gonna hunt you down dude you only
got a five point lead with a lot of
rounds to go
well you made a great point that as a
six point difference which is what it
was going into that round
you could make that up just literally
one point at a time
right one point around and you would
catch up so we are we
are going nowhere everybody this is
going to be a close finish this was the
puzzle
that ended uh jimmis 9 8 demetrius lota
pulos's run here
after queen h a queen g4 bishop h6 king
e7 queen e5
this position here i don't think he
played king d7 i think that was the mess
up
um because i remember seeing queen g4 on
the board but anyway
either way we know that there was no
mess up to bring up for ray maurice
because
ray was actually perfect through that
entire round he was just slower
than jimmis the entire time but ray
didn't miss any puzzles
and this was the one i believe jim has
played king d8
instead of king d7 but okay
we're gonna we're gonna be diving right
in here moving to the fifth round
any minute um i actually don't even know
if we're taking a break if we're running
away through but i think round five is
gonna start any second either way so
let's let's continue
okay but we've seen him show some
momentum making a mistake is not a big
deal
if you just shrug it off and keep
playing it's when you
react to your mistake when you feel the
power of the mistake
that you say oh i get i gotta hesitate i
don't want to do another one of those
but the champions like these guys they
make a mistake and they're able to
forget it like
a wide receiver scores a touchdown on
you you know
the safety's thinking so what you're not
doing that again that's how you have to
play
short memory and in puzzle three-minute
puzzle rush
you better have a short memory all right
i'm told we actually are taking a quick
break before we get to the back half and
ultimately the climax and crown a
champion here in 2021
for puzzle battle so we are going to
take a very very quick break
don't go anywhere when we return it's
the back half of the championship match
between grand master ray robson and
demetrius lotapulos
we'll be right back
[Music]
and here we go we are back with a small
lead for ray robson
as we head into the the final the final
set of rounds
with me grand master maurice ashley and
uh let's do it without any further ado
it's time for round five here between
ray robson
and demetrios lotto poulos let's go it's
it's getting we see demetrius has now
won two rounds in a row right even
though he trails overall
he's making headway and i i can't wait
to see what these final six sets bring
us so
the big issue danny the big issue is
will
ray have a collapse round he did have
that 39 score
and as they're about to go off and off
to the races
but will he have a round where he just
collapses and gives demetrius a chance
to pick up
a healthy 10 like he did against
demetrius
that's the hope so demetrius is going to
keep putting the pressure
he was down a lot but he's closed the
gap to just five right now
can he pull it down some more and make
ray feel like wait a minute this guy's
he's doing it he's doing it and mess up
that's going to be the key
yeah it's almost like the the thing that
um robert and i
said and i think hammer when he joined
too about magnus being in the scc
and and ultimately magnus did actually
lose for the first time in the sec but
we said it's almost like
what happens when when the champ gets
punched right right now it's been ray
in the lead and and jimmis is the one
dealing with the psychological
difficulties
but if ray if ray gets put on his heels
a little bit do we see any kind of
practical stuff
you know start to creep in right where
he clearly doesn't solve at the level
he's capable of so
so we'll see he's rolling that much
faster than ray at this point
i'm telling you he's feeling his
confidence level is high
at the moment as he's just whipping out
the puzzles but ray
you can expect ray to make a comeback
the puzzles so far have not been
ridiculously hard but
ray okay right now unless it looks like
both of them are killing these early
puzzles
we're down to a minute 30 right now
and it's plus two there's going to be a
puzzle danny there's going to be a
puzzle i'm waiting for it yeah one that
the mess up happens on
we'll see when it happens is right now
they're just playing like the best in
the world
yeah and they've they've they've been
here before they've seen a lot of these
puzzles even the ones that they haven't
they're
clearly in a comfort zone wow is this
the first time we've had both
or two players reach 40 and still be
perfect at the same i think i think so i
think so and ray made a
wicked comeback and has now seemingly
taken the small
smallish lead but nope there it is a
slight lead again
for demetrius he's up one wow up by one
now up by two
blink there but he's just saw i mean
monstrously solving these
readings are we about to have two
players reach 50 with no mistakes
no way no way he's got it
the demetrius got to 50 can ray join him
oh my gosh at all this is what a run
we are watching between these two
heavyweights
and i think we're going to see 60. are
we going to see 60
get showed up i think we're going to see
60. demetrius is on pace
for the first time i think of anyone
today to hit a 60 marker
and this is why this guy is so feared oh
and ray misses his first puzzle
that's big that's big we could close the
gap this round
he's at 59 and no mistake he made
60. we have a 60 for the first time
today but he does miss one
still a big score plus four
cutting the lead to just a single point
incredible what a matchup we're seeing
five rounds in the books a
big nugget of 60 and a one point
difference
mind this is crazy that is
that is the kind of round maurice that
we said could put ray
in the like what happens when the champ
gets punched right because
what what's in his head one he's blown
his lead right and two
jimmis is the first one to reach 60 not
ray robson not the defending champ so of
everyone who's played today 60 is not a
number you come by easily by the way how
much more impressive does it make
does this make their all-time scores of
69 and 68 right how did they ever do
that
that was crazy i mean this is nuts and
they're about to go right
at it again it's a one-point difference
between the players
that's crazy the score that you see is
the differential that is being put
up and rey was at 13
after the second round there we go he is
stuck
on that 13 points and it's jimmis who
has
who has won three rounds in a row
and dropped the 60. and look at this
score right now
15 10 what i don't know what happened
here even though they're both
actually solving what almost looked like
the same puzzle i think
maybe not maybe way ahead
well no no ray is now closing the gap
but i wonder if ray was like not paying
attention or something i don't know what
happened there at the start
maybe the maybe they're going so fast
the computer's not registering
i have no idea i mean they're going so
quick 25 already
in less than a minute and
and now they're just in their comfort
zone oh and jimmis makes his first slip
up in four rounds everyone after that
slow start you see on that scoreboard
56-41
uh demetrius lotapulos has been has been
the better solver in many ways but but
that was a slip up
all right he's still in the lead though
would that slip up could be significant
because two more and he might get frozen
out
and ray could add numbers so you see
here he's paused just for a moment
because he doesn't want to mess up
and that has cost him he's now down two
to ray
the hesitation now down four the
hesitation after you mess up because you
don't want to get the second strike
yep now down five i saw for a second
back to four
he needs to catch his flow again raised
perfectly in flow
and he and he's solving all of these
puzzles like he's seen them before this
looks like a round
where ray robson's work is paying off
because i mean he's perfect
he's perfect after 40 and okay right as
i say that of course he messes up
commentators curse but
but he hadn't had a single puzzle that
stumped him
well 44-41 what happens when the champ
gets punched in the mouth we're seeing
it he
the the champ gets stronger i mean the
wolf comes out
says no i've got to put back a number i
was up 10 and one
i was up 13 at one point and the score
is now
just one point separating them but wow
here demetrius this is not his round
necessarily but he's got to stay close
if he just loses by one or two it's okay
there's a lot of rounds to go
but he cannot let ray separate himself
and
we see here just a one point difference
i was going to say it it seems like like
demetrius is
not going anywhere he's but he lost he
he messed up again though
i didn't see it he just had his second
strike now he's really got to slow down
that hurts
and he made his third strike can ray
build wow
ray has got to stay focused can he put
his first 60 of the day
i'm gonna find out he's got five seconds
to solve it and he does
do it he's hit 60 with one second left
oh my gosh and look at that head bob
he's like yeah baby i'm back
bringing it the champ showing what he's
made of
right there and then a big spread eight
points the lead had been cut to one have
you ever watched
nba basketball let me tell you i'm a
big nba fan if you don't know everybody
on my stream knows
i rock the knicks all day even now being
from brooklyn
when you see a basketball game where
there's a big lead the run
that the the team that's behind makes
they come back
but they have to tie the score or take
the lead because the team that had the
lead to start with
they will start a push and push you
backwards and that could be demoralizing
and this is what happened here
he cut it to one and then boom
an eight-point spread it's like an 8-0
run
in basketball this could be rough it's
it climbs all the way back in
this means this next round to me it'll
be the decider
this could be the knockout blow if rape
puts up another five when this happened
in real time murray's you called it it
was the second strike right that first
one doesn't seem to slow them down
and it shouldn't right keep keep being
confident trusting yourself but the
second strike and this was the one that
ray
solved uh and found the idea of rook d
to b8 not rook a to b8
and the idea is you then play a5 and the
back rank is a serious problem
with the pin on the bishop and uh
demetrius
did not solve that correctly ray did and
it might have been the difference in
that in that particular
critical sixth round so all right well
round seven is going to be coming up
here just had to show that
that second strike and i'm like you said
i i'm with you it's a momentum
thing right you you punch him in the
mouth ray rises to the occasion and
punches right back
and uh we'll see what we'll see what
demetrius is made of right here in round
seven
don't forget ray won the first two
matches demetrius won the next three
now rey has won one it's a three three
match score
but rey's wins have been decisive
two of them so it's got to be right now
that demetrius delivers
he's got to i'm going to tell you
straight up if he doesn't deliver now
this match is over
that's my opinion got to deliver right
now with a
decent score maybe a plus three or a
plus four to feel like he's still in it
it's funny and you and i could probably
talk basketball day but i've been really
into
you know basketball like that you know
called the sabermetrics the stats that
kind of say
among all the best teams how do we know
early in a season who the best of the
best
are right and one of the things they
track is that margin of victory because
it kind of shows when the team is
right when the team is feeling it and
everyone's clicking how badly are they
beating teams right
and you just said something that made me
think of that that when rey is right
he wins by a lot right and it's
interesting to see there right because
when dmitry or or put it put it the
other way it shows who the to the maybe
the less consistent teams are
when demetrius isn't right it feels like
he kind of loses it right he goes on
tilt a little bit and that's been the
difference is that ray
when wright is getting big big scores
that's a big point
uh you demetrious can put up big numbers
he can put the numbers
in the 50s like no problem you see that
he can do that
but the one that he lost big was a 41
that was huge by the way they both
just missed that they both just missed
puzzle number 30.
right he gets a 52 and loses by eight
that's ray showing how much of a boss he
is so you get the combination of
you don't get your number or the other
guy puts up a number you go
what am i supposed to do when he does
yeah right
well we'll take a look at that uh 30th
puzzle everybody so
don't go anywhere we'll we'll make sure
that we see what both of them missed
they both played queen takes d1 in the
final position and i
can't wait to see what murray says about
that one so we'll come back to it but
all right right now
what matters is dimitri regardless ray's
running fast
yep this is critical guys this is it
ray's running
super fast plus five at the moment
ray better slow down as far as the
demetrius fans are concerned
because otherwise this could be problems
as demetrius tries to close the gap but
it's still five points
yep demetrius feels to have lost a
little bit of his uh his momentum and
and his feel for these positions he's
taking on average it looks like a second
or two longer than ray
oh and he misses his first puzzle number
43.
sorry second muscle second puzzle yeah
and
it's still okay the problem is there's
22 seconds left
he cannot afford to mess up now and let
ray
messed up he did and ray can add to the
number
he's up six at the moment with only one
puzzle gone he's up
seven he could go he's now up eight and
reign he's like a runaway
thoroughbred right now just look at the
number plus
eight this plus nine
this is ray roxton the world champion
showing his stuff
he finishes at 55. we see gymnast9a
demetrius slaughterpools hasn't sat
down since that round fell and and uh
right on cue he he comes right back to
the to the table there but wow that was
a
i i'm with you maurice and you know
anything can happen because we still
haven't seen ray put up a stinker i mean
he might be due right even the best in
the world have bad rounds
so so but demetrius fans better be
praying that that happens here right
because now
what a lead an 18-point lead i want to
bring up the third puzzle
um sorry the 30th puzzle that each of
them missed because i just want to see
what happened here um wow look at this
one marie so
they both i saw it in real time this one
i know for sure they both found
the first few moves oh no no they both
found b5
and then they took d1 because they both
missed queen takes back
backward moves backward moves get you
every time
that is absolutely wrong but you and
robert hess
two guys i do commentary with him both
make points with that a lot what is that
about the backward move it's just the
psychology or just the optics of the
board right you're just so much likely
to miss those
totally the optics no question about it
human beings
look at the world through our eyes
forward we don't have eyes in the back
of our heads
if we did backward would be a way we
would we would see and navigate very
easily somebody comes up to you from
behind you feel the ebg bees
it's just the way we are this way the
world the mind is wired and that gets
transferred onto the chess board
and backward moves just just don't see
them as easily yep
and now the score is huge look at that
30 to 12
you said he needs to have one bad round
danny sorry
he needs to have two horrible rounds to
lose this
ray needs to drop blood eight points
this is the title right here i think the
master is
because uh because yeah ray is putting
on a show and like you said when you're
putting up a 52 spot in rounds
but look at the difference right when
when demetrius put up a 60
right in round five ray got a 56 when
ray did a 60
demetrius was four puzzles worse right
so it's just and again it's
you know these two guys are the best
that's why they're here but it's been
the story of what has separated ray
robson from others is it's just the
consistency when you hit those
high 40s 50 puzzles 50 50 level puzzles
and ray already had his bad round it's
called round three
that was his background hollywood has
look at the score of round three there
maurice they both
that must have been a super odd round
where the algo happened to throw them a
ton of puzzles they hadn't seen because
that is
for those two guys a 39 and a 46 is is
epically low
definitely but my my question to you how
many rounds did ray score
under 50 only one one
round ask the same question of his
opponent
four rounds where he scored in the 40s
and that is the difference in the match
yeah no well said it's the consistency
there and now we see
uh jimmis does miss his first puzzle
he's in the lead but he any
i like what he's doing here even if he
goes down in flames maurice look at
even missing that puzzle he is still
blazing he knows that
he has no chance unless he's going to be
dropping mid 50s consistently and he's
got to risk getting some wrong in the
process
agreed agreed that's exactly right and
he's up
for okay he's pausing now while rey's
he's catching up and there it was
another error
and can he afford to keep blitzing which
he probably has to do
can he not afford to keep blitzing
yeah he's got 51 but here comes ray not
going away
yeah then when you have two wrong you're
just going to hesitate it's just a blink
of a hesitation
but you don't want to make that third
mistake with 42 seconds left
you just don't want to you you don't
want it and
yeah maybe ray ray has a perfect score
ray is looking to get
60. and the third mistake the end of the
match
that was that is it that is it
mathematically
he will not be able to catch ray no
matter what and rey is aiming for 60
again
you ask what happens when you punch a
champion in the mouth wow
this is what you see look at him leaning
in he wants 60.
we can't even see him anymore because oh
and he gets his first wrong that was a
wait what is what what the bleep i've
never seen this before and and that
looks like a weird puzzle
well he's at 58 can he do it
at 60 look at him he wanted the 16 just
not messed up
one but that is it the the match is
mathematically over right rockstar
but it's over well we'll start we'll
start round nine
right away here and uh as it's a matter
of formalities unless
unless jimmis resigns the match i'm not
exactly sure
how that works we i don't know that we
plan for it to be over in eight rounds
so we're i'm
i'm gonna let the team decide but if
we're continuing we'll start right away
here we go
yeah we're gonna play it all out for the
fans right for the fans
um but you're right maurice it's
mathematically over
no matter what happens here in the final
two rounds ray robson defends his title
as puzzle battle world champion and i'm
gonna say
well the way he's doing i probably
should shut my mouth but it's possible
very possible that ray scores his first
his second score
under 50. it's possible yeah yeah and he
i won't say this because you you kind of
hinted at it i i think with your tone
there and i
marie ray has been just one of the
classiest guys we've seen in any any
puzzle event we've done
i mean you'll notice even in the end of
the match with ikaro right he wasn't
putting on the heat in fact
you can claim a win instead of
continuing to to beat your opponent you
can actually just press a claim win
button the moment they get their third
strike
and he said he did that several times
today against his opponent so he is uh
ray is a very classy guy he's not
interested in rubbing salt in anyone's
wounds
so i wouldn't be surprised if you're
right if he kind of kind of slows down
the gas here in the final couple rounds
uh we're saying that and yet he's at 28
with no mistake so far
it's true maybe yeah maybe not gonna be
in flow
he knows that this is the only person in
the world
who challenges him at this right so
maybe he wants to say to him not again
yeah i was going to say not again i'm
going to i'm going to have you remember
this beat down
so next year you're thinking the same
thing because you know demetrius have
been dreaming about this for a whole
year this rematch
and what happened the same thing again
yeah i was going to say that's the other
angle is no no i'm i'm going to rub it
in because i want him to remember how
this feels
but we'll know the moment of truth if
demetrius gets a third strike
and ray claims a win then uh then then
we'll see but um right now
as we applauded last round even if he
gets a third strike i agree with
demetrius strategy of just
going as fast as he can because it's
kind of what you have to do but at this
point it's um
okay so the third strike has occurred
we'll see if ray claims the winner
continues so ray is going ray now hits
42 with
no errors whatsoever with a ton of time
on his clock
will ray claim the win or will we try to
get that 60 spot again
i mean no he'll never make 60.
not with this amount of time left we see
he's still
still going here and here it's just
in fact it's it's it might be likely
that he'll only stay in the 40s again
like i said just because he doesn't feel
the same pressure on himself anymore
he does have enough time to break into
50 something
if he solves the next two puzzles pretty
quickly but
he's not at that same frenetic wild
pace yeah it looks like he will make it
to 50 but again just
barely because the feeling isn't the
same anymore you know you've won you
don't
need to rack up the numbers and there he
is at 51.
wow wow wow there were a couple puzzles
there 51
51 is his second lowest
score shame on him shame on him
wow pick up your game man that shows how
bad at 39 was
but man this is sick this is there there
were a couple
too that he saw there that i was just
shaking my head i was like what i mean
the way he was it i don't remember which
one it was but we're going to start the
next round because at this point
out of respect for demetrius a lot of
poulos we won't delay
the event any further though we will
have an interview with
our uh champion so don't go anywhere
we'll catch up with ray robson and talk
to him about all things puzzles i i want
maurice to ask him some questions about
about his love for puzzles because uh
it's something that they they share
and uh maybe ray should tune into your
channel from time to time yeah yeah and
just saw all my puzzles and ruin it for
everybody who's following
i mean the guy's a beast certainly would
love to have him on the show at some
point
uh we'll we'll see about that uh but
just simply extraordinary the speed of
which he solves
yeah and uh you know out of the gates
it's one of the things that's funny
it in the early most the time today
mary's correct if i'm wrong but it
it feels like up to the 25 marker and
even the 30 marker gymnast is actually
the faster with his mouse right he's
actually the faster player he tended to
be reaching
27-28 before ray did a lot of the time
um but it's when the puzzles hit the the
the 40s and 50s that where the
consistency kicks in
and and the speed is slightly less
important yeah interesting observation
you've got to solve those puzzles i mean
when you get to 60 puzzles
that means you're solving the puzzles
all
solving everything in five seconds a
puzzle
right you're averaging five seconds five
seconds to look at a tough chest
position
and without a blank like bing bing bing
bing and just
go for it just really ridiculous speed
you give a difficult puzzle a difficult
chess position
to a player and you solve it in five
seconds
the whole thing not just solve it and
that's assuming they get them all right
right if they miss one then you know
yeah that's
amazing you're right though how did they
get to 68
like what is what well like what in the
world right
it has to be one of those perfect runs
where you know
the algorithm randomly delivers them a
whole so at that point it's
purely mouse speed right and they they
probably didn't miss any
and they probably had a lot of puzzles
they had seen before and it worked out
speaking of not missing any raise at 52
no mistakes and
52 seconds left on his clock
will we see an absurd number
put get put up 60 looks well within
reach wow
is he going to score one of his best
scores ever what a statement round it
would be and look at him still
rocking these puzzles at 56. 58 he's
perfect at 58.
he's got 60. he's gonna oh no as soon as
i said it
he's made a mistake but he's got 59 he's
going to
get 60 looks like yeah and there it is
he's going to score his best score
of the whole day but look and look at
gymnasts we're going to have 260s here
as long as jimmys can deliver on his
final puzzle
that's right look at that he's not into
the 60s in the last round
62 by ray it looks like he'll end up
around 64.
poetic number for chess no he didn't
well yes he does yes he did
yes he did and you called it
and he closed out best number incredible
both of them showing what stars
i mean they and jimmis sorry demetrious
a lot of poulos i keep saying jimmy's
because his name
uh his username but shout out to him
because he goes down but not without a
fight putting up his best score of the
entire day
in the last round even knowing that it
was a moot point
at that at that point so wow maurice
this has been wild these guys have uh
have entertained us and i can't wait to
to hear what ray has to say so don't go
anywhere when we return
we will have our final thoughts on the
day and interview
with the back-to-back puzzle battle
world chess champion if you're out there
kids
and uh and you want to be like ray
robson someone's got to beat this man in
the next few years so
somebody start solving some puzzles to
take this guy out
maurice and i will be back with an
interview and final thoughts in just a
moment
[Music]
and we are back with our now
back-to-back
puzzle battle world chess champion ray
how does it feel knowing that you took
home this time 8k
and you had to win it all to get to get
any money
yeah uh it feels really good um
yeah i don't know i think i felt a lot
of pressure um
coming into this event and obviously i
didn't really know what the
what the bracket was going to be who was
going to be playing until just the other
day
um so then i saw obviously jimmy's was
really my main competition and it seemed
like we're destined to meet in the
finals so
i was waiting for this match for for a
little while now
and yeah i was was pretty nervous
um i think we both were
and yeah i think it was tough for both
of us to play in this fight
ray you played last year he played the
same opponent last year you know
he must have been working his tail off
the whole year
for this moment alone you do other
things obviously as a top player
what's it like to know that there's one
thing in this person's mind and that's
to beat
you i i don't know if i would describe
it that way i'm
i'm pretty sure he does other things um
he does play chess himself over the
board he probably has played more over
the board than me in the past year
um and i'm i'm not sure that he's
actually
spent more time than me i'm not sure
that anyone spent more time with me
in practicing puzzle rush so i think
that's actually
my biggest advantage over over everyone
is i've just
um i've just done it more often than
anyone else i think
well again talk about that i mean we i
feel like i want to ask you similar
questions that i did
last year and tell similar stories where
when your coach alex ownership when you
were 16
told me i needed to add more 3000 plus
puzzles because ray was solving all of
was memorizing them and i didn't believe
him right and then and then when puzzle
rush launched and
you sort of took the world by storm with
this secret spicy caterpillar username
and then i made you reveal who you were
because we had to make sure people knew
that it was a real thing so
i mean how many puzzles would you say
you've solved at this point and
when you reach that mid-40s mark up to
the the mid 50s
how many of those have you seen before
on average
so i mean i i can't calculate how many
i've solved that's probably
i mean someone someone else would do
that better than me
um i mean you can see people's attempts
how many attempts they've done in
puzzle rush so i assume i have you know
probably the most
um but a lot of those are me trying to
get like high scores so i'm
i'm going really fast in the beginning
and if i strike out early i just end so
they're not really full
attempts but um for for the 40 50 the
harder puzzles
it depends like probably in the past i
think most of the top guys would have
known almost all of them but you guys
are always adding puzzles so um
there's there's definitely um puzzles
that are
in the more difficult range that we
don't know and um
also recently i think you guys had a lot
of like tricky puzzles that are actually
much earlier on and that is why i think
some of our scores weren't as consistent
as
maybe it seemed like they were going to
be going in
do you have a secret beyond practice
i mean is it is it just practice is
is is it do you study
the other puzzle like puzzle books or
go over studies by by great play
great people like trotsky and rink and
all those guys
that you translate that into this skill
set
or is it just about raw solving of these
puzzles
well you need to have some sort of
background in
puzzle solving tactical ability so
obviously all the work i did as
a regular chess player or one of my main
strengths was
tactics and calculation that obviously
helped a lot and that still helps um in
the early puzzles
but i mean of course it helps in the
harder more difficult puzzles as well
but um yeah and this type of format
it's really like to be able to solve
those puzzles as quickly as
as let's say jimis and i we're solving
um some of those rounds
there's there's no way anyone can
humanly do that unless they've just seen
the puzzle enough times
and i mean people have different methods
of going about
trying to learn the puzzles some people
like directly just
search um for maybe specific rating
range and they try to just memorize
puzzles
um i don't think jimison i do that
uh i mean i'm not sure about jimmy's but
i don't think he does the way i do it is
i just play a lot
and so i just see a lot of puzzles and
then if i get them wrong
i just review them so i'm not like
trying to memorize every single problem
in the database but
just by playing so much i'm encountering
most of the
most difficult puzzles
it's it's wild it's mind-blowing it's
honestly amazing and it has
even you know super strong players and
grand masters just
in awe of what you guys can do um i
i don't even know that i i have many
other questions besides just again a
huge congratulations to you man
and how how many more years do you think
you can stay at the top i know i know
you're uh you're a super humble guy and
i'm not asking you for a bold statement
but at this point
two-part question do you think the
difference between you and jim is when
you get to that
hi to that mid 40s low 50s actually
is chest strength because maurice and i
talked a lot about this and said like
hey
what makes rey special is he's a puzzle
specialist
right like demetrius but you're also a
very strong grandmaster and it does seem
that
where the rubber meets the road there in
the tougher puzzles is where you're able
to separate and be a little more
consistent
so do you think it's chest strength that
maybe separates you and gimmicks
like general chest strength and two how
long do you think you could be at the
top
um i mean chess strength
it helps somewhat but i mean like
bashir or hikaru are stronger players
than me and
they don't if they played against
gymnasts it's most likely they'll lose
right um so it's not just about
chest strength um and i don't know i
actually think that the harder puzzles
often favor the like give less of an
advantage to the so-called stronger
player just because
those are the ones that people have
probably seen a lot and might have
remembered um and like so if
if we both remember the same and i think
james is not slower than me and
mouse speed um it's not really
confirming much of an advantage so i'm
not really sure
what the difference was today um i felt
like he did miss
more puzzles than i was expecting in the
in those later ones
and i'm not really sure perhaps he
hadn't
practiced as much as me recently or
maybe he was just nervous i'm not sure
what happened exactly
um because usually um he is doing better
in this
and as far as the trying to retain the
title
um yeah i don't know i to be honest
i'm probably not gonna play as much
puzzle rush
next year i probably i'm gonna like try
to become 2700 fee day
that's my my main goal right now um
so i don't know like if other people
if they keep it up um i have no clue
perhaps i could
i mean i could definitely lose um next
year even
um so it's really hard to say the one
thing i will say is um
i hope that in future years um you have
some sort of format which is
more like the like the first year like
last year where
it's a little bit more open so that
people can try to qualify because i know
a lot of
strong strong puzzle specialists who
would have loved a chance to play but
this one was kind of invitation only
it's fair
yeah and uh just because you asked we're
going to do it next year there's an open
qualifier you heard it it'll be done
maurice any final thoughts before i give
a huge shout out that everyone needs to
go join you at your channel
well congratulations ray in a topic that
i am going to talk about on my channel
uh in a moment is about the difference
between
solving puzzles and playing chess at the
elite level
i mean you made this point you don't
want to keep doing this you want to be a
2700 player
what's the difference why is it that you
could be such a dominant puzzle solver
but not be the best players in the world
um well first of all puzzle solving is a
specific
ability you know that there's one
solution
there's supposed to be one solution
sometimes you guys have multiple
solutions or
or your solution is actually not a
solution but in general there's there's
one solution
oh there was the rook and i
remember the brook and bishop versus
rook from today
about that that one was uh that was a
bad puzzle
i called myself out on it just so you
know and we're gonna remove that one but
that was a super unfair
puzzle and hikaru got lucky and got it
right you played a move that should have
been winning but
but it wasn't right um but yeah
so there's only one solution so and it's
usually tactical
um so you kind of know what to look for
if you're familiar with a lot of the
the patterns that are common in just
tactics and in studies
in particular then you already have an
advantage
and obviously with something like puzzle
rush it's very specific where you kind
of have
uh you're kind of seeing a lot of the
same patterns over and over
so over time you just adapt to those um
but by the way maurice i really i've
seen your stream i really like your your
stream is very good
so everyone should check out more recent
stream um and i think for
like let's say if there were five minute
puzzle rush battles
i think that's where i would have more
of an advantage in the harder puzzles
compared to
someone um lower rated but
also you know people like kikaro's other
really strong players would
also have more of an advantage there so
two requests
the reigning world champion wants an
open qualification format
and you want five-minute puzzle battles
i can definitely deliver on the first
one
we'll see about the second but anyway
right no uh jokes aside
it's awesome again this is this is super
super entertaining and educational for
for the the viewers can't wait till next
year so uh so thanks thanks and again
congratulations
congratulations thank you my co-host
grand master maurice ashley i'm gonna
i'm gonna sign off and again
congratulate the world champion
and uh thank you both make sure everyone
sticks around we're about to raid grand
master mauricio
maurice ashley's channel which is why
we're letting him go and ray
congratulations again to you
all right thanks so much guys bye guys
all right guys
all right well there you have it fans
and we still more than 9000 of you that
stuck around for that interview
on just twitch alone and so we hope that
you stick around
and uh join us with the raid party
following grand master maurice ashley at
his channel
the bracket is before your very eyes
this is what happened today everyone
grandmaster ray robson defends his title
is once again the puzzle battle world
chess champion
and uh but it was it was close like like
he said he felt that him and jimmys were
both
nervous today him and demetrius a lot of
poulos um
and maybe they weren't at their absolute
best overall but
either way their last round they did to
give us a show 64 and 61 respectively it
was crazy so
anyway congratulations to ray again who
shows that uh
shows that he has still demanded beat
this was our final bracket score
in front of you here we've got uh what
was overall
as maurice and i drew the conclusion it
was just a little more consistency from
ray
and you also saw when he won he won
bigger
right the round the demetrius put up a
60 there in round five
ray kept pace right but when ray put up
uh it was it was a wider margin of
victory right and that ultimately is why
he he walked away with a 48 to 12 score
even though it felt
much much closer than that so well again
thank you to everyone this has been an
awesome week if you didn't get the memo
here's your last reminder it's
free puzzle battles for everyone today
on chess.com
as a celebration of all of chess.com's
puzzle features come to an end
we've had puzzle rush three minute
puzzle rush survival puzzle rush five
minute
multiple puzzle battle events and it all
came down to this championship
where ray robson took the title home so
uh
go check out and try out puzzle battles
on chess.com it is free if you haven't
yet
for the whole crew here working super
hard our events team all of our mods and
staff that make this possible thank you
so much for all the hard work you've
done not just today but this entire week
for my awesome co-host who we are rating
grandmaster maurice ashley go to his
channel and hit that follow button you
won't regret it
seriously it's one of the most needs to
be talked about more things happening on
twitch right now because maurice's
streams are super educational and
awesome so
for the crew for the team for everybody
like i said thanks for being here
and we will see you next week on
chess.com tv
[Music]
so
you